I feel like as a third party to this, I feel way worse about
streaming this than Nick does. I'm almost positive I feel worse
about this than he does. Can I >> God forbid I want a husband
instead [laughter] of a clown chasing streamer?
>> Keep it up and you'll get neither.
What the?
Okay.
All right. Well, I mean, we might as well get to the
Nick Lee content. Asig Gold has walked away. Let's just do this
real quick and then we can do the Clav stuff after. We'll see
what's going to happen. Okay.
Now, I will ask if anybody knows. I've not gone backwards in
this VOD yet to check it out, but I do know that basically Amaranth
was like in his chat before this. I tried I tried pulling it
up. So, I've got Amaran's logs here of what she was saying when
she was in the chat. Now, I think somewhere around here, somewhere
around here is where she goes starts. So, 40 41 minutes. Let's
go about 41 minutes back and see if we can find this 41. So,
9:04
96. It's 25
8:25 or so.
should be somewhere around here. >> What are you talking
about? They messed it up. That's just them not
doing it. But also, why would you think if I was plotting an
inside job >> and those guys messed it up? A, did I know
they messed it up? B, if I knew they messed it up, then my plan.
>> So, he must be talking about the robbery that happened,
right, with his pigeon on his head. Let's go. my co-conspirators,
but them in such a way that it was measured and controlled because
my priority was not to hit you. Oh, wait. That already doesn't
drive when I just mag dumped down the stairwell. That's the two
birds with one stone. Like, it >> I mean, I don't know
if you get away with that, to be honest. >> Doesn't make
sense to be like, and he gingerly, you know, was very careful
to take only controlled shots. >> Did I I don't know. I
didn't see this in her logs. I don't think
this is She comes in somewhere around here and says, "Are you
talking [__] about me instead of coming to bed?"
Sad. I didn't miss it, did I? >> No. I mean, we had a panic
room and I could have gone in and locked myself in and they'd
never get to me. That's the thing I'm saying. Like, it's like
I chose a course of action and I chose
>> I didn't have to choose engagement.
There's two easy ways I could have chosen not engagement. >> Oh,
here we go. You're arguing logic when I already said I understand
it was a bad state of mind. Okay. Where is that? You're arguing
logic. Oh, so it's still 40 minutes back from here that we have
to go. Okay. Well, we're going to do this. We're in for the real
thing here. So, we're actually going all the way back. Okay.
I think it's somewhere around here. >> I remember all the
way back. >> There was a closet that we don't use as much
in this house and I went to it and the door was jammed. I couldn't
open the >> We're gonna turn it up. Okay. We're gonna turn
it up. And then you hear like
and what happened is I pulled the door because the wood in the
frame was a little bit I guess moist so rotten. So I pulled one
of the hinges out of the the door frame and then she went the
vampires in Twilight are super strong.
>> I was like what? >> Ah he's doing more of the
So Amaranth is >> that's not normal man. >> I I do
wonder why he's on stream 7 and 1/2 hours into his stream. I
wonder if anybody who's watching this enough to start like talking
about it. Seven and a half hours, seven hours, 45 minutes into
his stream, he's like talking about how his wife's crazy. It's
like I Dude,
probably not gonna lead to a happy life. Okay, it's like the
opposite of a happy >> Also Twilight related. I was talking
to the staff
and this is back, this is sad a little bit, but like she really
wanted to do a streamed wedding with me as one of the big splash
make a big splash things when she went right back to Twitch,
right? And so someone was saying, "Well, how do we want to frame,
you know, uh the vows and the things,
And I was like, you know, I mean, we'll just frame it like this.
It's like, you know, have been working together at this for a
long time. We've been ups and downs, but like, you know, we're
resolved to be a team, you know, and, you know, we're ready to
take on the future, you know, together.
And then my employee, who was one of my better employees ever,
it's one of the top three best ones. >> Oh, there it is.
Are you talking about me instead of coming to bed? Sad. >> But
is that a compelling love story or like a compelling enough.
>> Okay, that's important context to understand that he
was clearly actually talking before she says anything. Okay,
bad time to tune in and see what you're doing. She says over
here, okay, bad time to tune in and see what you're doing. Hold
on, let me pull up my OBS. Make sure it's coming through correctly.
So, she's just like, wait, why are you why are you [__]
talking me on your stream live right now? Now, as people who've
been following us for a long time, we watch their therapy stuff.
We know that they're not supposed to talk about each other on
each other's streams. That's bad for them. Story to get people
invested in watching a streamed wedding.
And I shrugged and I said, "It's still better love story than
Twilight." And Kate overheard that. And she goes, "A vampire
reference."
I was like, "What?" And those those texts of her recalling that
situation made it back to the lawyer.
And his only response was, you know, I'll add it to the file.
>> Okay.
All right. >> That was a conniving mother.
You know, even though she was going on on this vampire tangent,
that dude had his daggers ready.
Not sure this guy's low cow status or if he's actually getting
popular. Um, many very popular streamers are loss. They just
manage to keep their like drama a little bit lower key than their
like actual content they're doing. I don't know about Nick yet.
Um, I would have never thought Nick could get this. Well, I knew
Nick could get far because he can yap, right? He can yap infinitely
about everything all the time. He can just consistently sit here
yapping about anything. So, that's like already a lot for stream
is just to be able to fill dead air all the time, consistently
talk. It doesn't have to be sensical. It doesn't even have to
be entertaining. It just has to be noise. Okay. And then he went
and joined up with the Ice Besidon guys, the CX crew, and he
is probably like significantly
more intelligent and capable than almost anybody Ice Boseidon's
ever worked with before, which is really not the compliment it
sounds like. All right.
I So,
but I don't know. I thought for me personally when we watched
I think Ice was kind of crashing out in front of him with the
bulletproof vest a couple days ago and when we watched that I
comment that I'm like I'm wondering I'm wondering how Nick and
Aaranth are doing cuz I'm guessing like now that Nick has his
own outlet maybe things are just like way better for them. I
hope they're way better for them. Like I I think they could be
way better for them now that he has his own way to like have
control over his stream and and talk to people and do all of
his own stuff. I think things could easily be going way better
for them. And then
um then today came along and I got messaged by about a hundred
different people going, "Did you know that there's like Amaranth
and Nick Lee Crasho content again?"
>> I wished >> to disallow me to live at my own home
even before the asset division because I might pose a serious
risk to her because
she texted him that I might be a
>> Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, wait.
Hold on. And did he just say he's going to get more money in
a divorce because Amaranth texted the lawyer that Nick is a vampire?
Why? That doesn't make any sense.
she texted him that I might be a vampire. You know what? Never
mind me. >> I don't believe you when you say this. I have
to listen again. >> That I might be a vampire.
>> One more time. >> Please allow me to live at my
own home even before the asset division because I might pose
a serious risk to her because
she texted him that I might be a >> Okay. So, it's just
that he was saying he might be a vampire and that's why she didn't
want him there. >> You know what? That reminds me. I'm
going to put
>> again. He's like taking something that's like totally
private for the person he loves and you should just move away
from if you're going to do this.
Like I I man, it's just so rough to watch, right?
Yeah. It's so rough to watch. It's like dude, if you care about
this person, if you're married to them, like these are the last
things you should be sharing on a stream. You can you can walk
away from that if you if you need to, man. If you feel like,
oh, this is too much, you walk away from it. But this is the
last thing that you get like the moral green light to do,
right? This is I really don't like it. And he's done it so many
times now that it's hard to count.
You just don't share things about them. Like, stop sharing things
about >> $10,000 more dollars in the retainer to sue that
ex employee. Give me a second. >> Okay. So, when are we
expecting the next amaranth message?
about 10 minutes after the previous shootings. So, we'll see.
>> That was wild. That was pretty wild. That was a wild
attempted motion. >> I don't think it was a Wait, I don't
think it was a motion. That's You're not in court. Somebody text
your lawyer. That's not a motion. There any lord to who Nick
was before Amaranth like jobwise or something? Yeah, I think
he's a mechanical engineer, electrical engineer. He's like an
engineer like a by education and he had a job at a pretty successful
like he had a job a corporate job. He was making like really
good money for the age he was. He bought them a house and she
was doing like a a princess party planning thing.
And so he did set them up. He did like take care of both of them
financially while she got her princess business off the ground
and then while she got her cosplay thing off the ground and he
would cosplay with her. They cosplay together. Right. >> No,
we've already made up. I just said I mean you probably weren't
here but I said earlier that we're the best we've been like maybe
for uh forever.
I'm just reflecting on the situation and trying to explain.
I mean, earlier today I was saying that like it feels like things
are the best they've ever been.
Dude, then why the man I I actually weirdly believe him that
things have been good. I I figured everything must be good between
them. That makes this so much worse that you're sharing this.
Like that makes it so much worse that you're just going and sharing
a whole bunch of super private [__] for no reason,
[snorts] right? Like why why in the world would you be sharing
this stuff? Um he admitted to trafficker not that long ago. His
clip his clip ex account posted it. He admitted to committing
a felony crime. Wow. He must have gotten charged.
No, one people would never take like a statement made on a stream
as like an actual admission of guilt, right? They would use it
as evidence. It could go before a jury, but it's not like you
would just get charged because of that. Um, yeah, the statement
could be used, but I I don't think the police would charge based
on he said something like this as an influencer. I think people
really wouldn't take him that seriously >> ever in my life
across the board, including my relationship. And it's crazy to
me that the thing I really enjoyed doing, which is streaming,
I wasn't even doing at an earlier point this year or at any other
prior point in my life. And that our relationship
was so roller coastery that I saved her life and then we were
on this like honeymoon period for like a couple weeks and then
I was the most hated, you know, vampire
in existence and now we're back to being good again with only
ever so slightly the occasional wisp
of like is everything fine, you know? >> Uh the internal
brick four walls brick is crazy.
Um
that looks like a wallpaper to me. That doesn't look textured.
I'm trying to see. Is the light bouncing? Maybe the light's bouncing
correctly.
I thought
Yeah, I
I feel like it looks like wallpaper to me, but I can't tell.
They're rich, so would it would be weird if it was wallpaper,
but it looks like wallpaper to me. The corner. Yeah, I guess
the corner does look a little weird. You'd expect it to be more
textured here or have any texture, not just be solid. Although,
that looks like could be I don't know.
Can you imagine that? Wait. Wait. Who? Wait, hold on. What? >> God,
I hate that person. >> Is she not going to be mad at you
telling us then? >> God, I hate that. >> Can you
imagine that? Dude saves his wife from three armed gunmen, probably
saving her life. Within 60 days, you're trying to convince a
judge the dude is a threat to her. He needs to not be in the
home. Can you, >> man? I Dude, oh, I think we watched a
little bit of this part already. >> That it's like >> it's
rough, man. >> If he wasn't home that day, then the client
is not even here.
What are we saying? >> Uh, like your wife is clearly in
emotional distress and like suspicious of everything because
she had a traumatic thing happen.
Like there's a there's literally she had a traumatic event happen
and she's distrustful of everything. >> You're You think
that your your client is unsafe because he made a Twilight >> Like
I think Nick needs to get beyond the the point where like he's
treating this as if it's like logical, right? like she I know
it's it's not logical and you could keep like beating your wife
over the head with this or keep bringing it up to people and
going like it's not logical. It's not logical. Yeah, everyone
can see that. Everyone can see that she was like traumatized
that she was clearly having like an overreaction that she's clearly
like incredibly suspicious of you for with possibly like not
very much reason. I mean, I don't know what her reasons are.
If it's just like comments about vampires, that's probably going
to seem like not real to me. But I also wouldn't just dismiss
her out of hand. um on her being suspicious. There could be suspicious
stuff going on, right?
Um yeah, I don't know. This
I I feel like this is just rough. It's rough to watch. Somehow,
I'm not even joking. Somehow watching them screaming at each
other or watching Amaranth have a full-on like crying breakdown
is less painful to me than just this Nick sitting here when there's
not really anything wrong and he's going to just leak random
[__] about his personal life cuz he doesn't have
other content to do on stream right now. Like this actually feels
worse to me. Like it's more upsetting to me. I can handle them
screaming at each other. Then I'm like, "Oh, well, they're on
stream and they might be leaning into it. There's like other
things going on in my head." But for this, it's like, "Dude,
you're like, "Oh, things are better than they've ever been, but
can you believe she said this about It's like, dude, come on.
How are you spiraling on this still?" He's going to come in and
say something again here in second. >> But isn't that crazy?
Like, as a lawyer, and maybe that's why I'm not a lawyer,
that would give me the heebie-jebies to to even engage in that.
It's like on one hand you >> Well, hold on.
How does Nick know about it if the lawyer didn't tell him? It
sounds like the lawyer did have heebie-jebies and he probably
was like, "Hey, I think something's like wrong. Your wife sent
me something that doesn't make sense." >> We have allegations
of being a vampire
and you're going to turn that into a this guy needs to be evicted
from his own home because he's a danger to his wife whose life
he just saved during a home invasion. Bro, you want me out of
the house because of a Twilight joke?
I don't know. Um, I can think of like a lot of reasons why. Clearly,
demonstrabably me being home resulted in her being alive today.
>> He's Dude, this is like this is worse than the like
Aiden Ross moment where he's like, I do think Hassan wanted to
kill his dog. I think he wanted to kill fish right there when
he said, "I'm going to kill you if you don't listen to me." He
definitely was actually threatening to kill his dog. A bird definitely
just hit that camera, didn't it? A bird. A bird definitely just
flew into that camera. [laughter] Dude, what the [__]
You missed it. Hold on. I'll pull it back then. Right here. Oh,
maybe back a little further. Yeah, I think I went back far enough.
Give it a second. Oh, maybe not. I did. I did. >> Do you
get what I'm saying, though? >> You missed it twice. You
got to go back in my VOD then. Sorry. You don't see it. You just
hear it. >> Like that's a hard one to even settle in my
mind. See, it's not like I laid a hand on her. It's not like
I was destroying something in the house. It's not like I was
making violent statements. No, it was that she suspects me of
being a vampire and the lawyer was trying to twist that into
something that was actionable despite the fact that the thing
that he said, you know, the fear was, which is that I might harm
her, is demonstrabably untrue because I just saved her life.
What are we talking about here? Like I feel like demonstrated
actual reality shows that like she's better off with me being
here, but you're going to talk about Twilight. I >> mean,
I assume her mental state factors into that, but whatever with
this guy. I'm looking I think Amaran's supposed to say something
here pretty quick.
I'm looking I think it's supposed to be like right here. There's
supposed to be another Amaranth comments. >> God, it's
so [__]
>> We're watching for it. We're watching for it. There
it is. You know that when you're drinking blood
is true. >> Yeah, it's going to start going up. I'll pause
and read it to you and then I'll He might read it. I'm not totally
sure. I'll wait until it gets above the penguin. There it is.
Okay. Um well, I mean,
you told me you wish you hadn't saved me. That's when I broke
mentally because I apparently took it wrong. But water under
the bridge, I guess.
So, he's leaving out details, it sounds like. Okay.
Please don't tell my wife that my favorite delicacy
in Asian cuisine. >> Dude, there's no way. There's no way.
There's no way it's dogs. There's no way it's dogs. There's no
way he's about to say that. There's no way he's about to say
dogs. Come on, man.
>> I might for dinner tomorrow. >> I got it ready
and then I I I thought he was going to say dogs. My bad. So,
he's reading the messages back from Emaranth. I think feel like
he has to be aware that she said like, "Hey, could you not do
this right now?" Right? Conversation so far that she's thrown
out. I don't know if he really responded. Are you talking about
about me instead of coming to bed? Bad time to tune in to see
what you're doing. And then you wish you hadn't saved me.
And then 14 minutes later is the next comment. I might start
skipping ahead cuz I'm guessing he's going to like >> Basically,
what you're asking is that I not express something that I feel
>> the way apparently took it wrong. Water on the bridge.
He reads it. >> I mean,
it is water under the bridge, but like
in my defense,
the way you took it wrong was literally the way I prefaced what
I said by saying I don't want you to take it this way.
Start point. It's like I cannot like basically what you're asking
is that I not express something that I feel because there's no
form factor for expressing it so that you wouldn't feel like
that statement overweighed the action. Um,
wait. >> Like, think about it for a second. No matter how
much the words might sting, even when I prefaced it, I still
took action when it was time to take action. You can't fake.
>> So, even though I said I wish I hadn't saved you, I
did save you. So, come on. It doesn't save you. Saving you means
way more. >> Anyone can say
something that they don't mean when they're angry. I'm not even
saying I said that, by the way. I'm saying that anyone, it's
very reasonable. And we understand that some humans, your friend,
your spouse, your mother, your dad.
>> Hypothetically, if I did say that, I didn't say that.
But hypothetically, if I did say that, then that's something
normal human beings do. And you can't really hold that against
me. And also, I did save you anyway, so shut up. >> Your
father, your brother, anyone when angry might say something they
don't mean. That's a very axiomatic truth.
Now, you try and tell me that someone who's willing to risk their
life for your life
is just posture. Impossible.
Impossible.
because you can't posture that. You can't put your life on the
line for someone else's life. >> I mean, listen, I think
Nick stood tall. He did fire the shots at those guys. He made
them run away. I also think that
there's probably nearly basically every reason to believe that
he might have thought that they were there to put both of them
and that he was defending himself in either case, right? Like
he wasn't just defending Amaranth. There was were intruders into
his own home, right? I don't know. as a ploy. There ain't nothing
more valuable than your >> One second. I'm grabbing some
food. >> Do you understand that? And so it shouldn't have
mattered what I said, even though I I still say that like what
I said could not have been taken that way unless you're being
hyper dishonest about it. You know, like like I literally said,
I don't want you to take it this way, but here's the thing. And
then you go, I guess I took it the wrong way when you literally
took it the way I said don't take it this way. It's not what
I mean. I prefaced it. It came before the statement, you know.
And if you actually, which I still don't think you have, if you
actually listen to the words I'm saying, >> there's a very
specific reason why I'm saying it,
it's because I wanted to be able to talk to you and resolve
But you kept paving over, you know, what I was saying
by saying, "No, let's not talk about that. It doesn't matter.
You saved my life."
>> This just needed to be like a therapy session again.
And I'm just like, dude, how can me saving your life mean that
all of our issues don't need to be
>> and that our communication should break down because
saving your life is, you know, obviously, you know, overshadowing
any future need to communicate. >> Yes, birds are cool.
>> It doesn't make any sense.
>> Here's what I said, >> guys. Do not keep watching.
>> That you were not saved. It's just sometimes I wish
I wasn't the one who saved your life. You are Okay, I'm just
be honest. Look, if you take that any other way, because I'm
saying that I wish it was like, I don't know, a police officer
was going by and he saw the guys breaking in and he saved your
life. >> that's what it means. I said literally, I don't
want you to take the wrong way because obviously if it is about
saving your life, yes, of course, but sometimes I wish it wasn't
me who saved it.
You see, that doesn't say I'm saying I wish you died. What that
says is that sometimes I wish you weren't treating me so differently
for having done it that way because you'd also still be alive
if someone else saved you. Do you understand that? For you to
be like, "So you want me to die?" It's like, and then for that
to escalate to, "So you're gonna plot to kill me?" It's like,
not even We're not even in the same.
>> Yo,
Matt NLT, thank you for the five gifties. Let's go. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. I'll add that extra hour. I'm not going
to reset stuff. We'll just leave the timers up there and we'll
do at 60. We'll do the next hour. But thank you very much. Appreciate
it. Um, I can get where Nick would be upset here. He's he feels
like he has something on his chest that he has to get off of
it that he needs his wife to know that it's like upsetting him
and he feels like he has to vent it and he's got his wife to
vent to, right? And so he says, I'm going to premise this or
I'm going to preface this rather and please don't get mad, but
this is how I feel sometimes and it doesn't it's not like an
indictment and he can feel mad about that, right? On its face,
him venting here doesn't seem that crazy, barring the stipulations
he agreed to. This venting is not bad. The venting where he was
talking about his wife and the text that like seemed really crazy.
That venting was bad. Talking about his wife being like delusional,
trying to like imply she was crazy and he has to deal with that.
That's if that's too much of a burden for you, walk away.
I get I get how that's a burden. I don't need anybody. You don't
have to take that burden up if you don't want to. But yeah, he
was leaking earlier. It was pretty bad. It was pretty rough.
and she came in and was like typing in his chat and be like,
"Oh, I guess you're just talking about me then. Cool." Yeah,
it's already it's kicking off, you know, not in the best place.
This is understandable. Now, I will say
you have to have some empathy for her side of it, too, going
through the traumatic event, but I I understand how he's upset
by this. I think you try to be, you know, as the man of the house,
you're the masculine person. You try to be the person who's strong
for the other one. But I get how that's difficult, man. >> I
I didn't actually say I wish the cop saved her. I just said I
wish it was anybody else who stepped in and saved you and it
wasn't me because it seems like because it is me. You're saying
that that warrants us not ever talking or trying to resolve an
issue because they're not important. The sad part is this, right?
Obviously in every relationship, you know, communication is key,
right? Imagine if you're dating someone or you're married to
someone and then you go, "Hey, uh, this thing you did, it makes
me unhappy or uncomfortable." And your partner says, "It doesn't
matter. We're more important than that. I won't talk about it."
It's like, well, that's very high road of you, but it's me that
feels the problem. If it was you that felt the problem and you
resolved it by saying, but us is more important than this unresolved
feeling. Sure, but you can't choose to sacrifice someone else's
grievance.
>> Do you understand that? >> Yeah, that could be
frustrating.
>> I feel like you don't. He's talking to his wife through
his stream. >> Two people are talking about an issue and
one has unresolved feelings and the other one says, "No, it's
resolved." It's like, bro, we're just you're you're in denial.
Cuz if one person feels like it's not resolved, then it's not
resolved. It's the person who doesn't feel like it's resolved.
You get what I'm saying? Like it's it's like the same. I'll give
you an example. It's like saying like uh are we on the same page?
You know,
and then you know, you say, "Yes, we both agree that there's
no demons." And you be like, "No, no, no. I don't agree with
that." Is ammo in his chat? She was in his chat earlier. Yes.
Uh next message we're looking at, we've read, "Are you talking
[__] about me instead of coming to bed?" That was
about 30 minutes ago. Bad time to tune in and see what you're
doing. Well, I mean, you told me you wish you hadn't saved me.
That's what broke me mentally. or that's one I broke mentally
because apparently I took it wrong. But water under the bridge,
I guess. And then he keeps talking. He goes, "Wonder under the
bridge as I premised or sorry, amaranth response, water under
the bridge as I premised." I don't I don't know if we've seen
this one yet,
it's like what? No, no, no. You throw the word result on it doesn't
mean it's done. Doesn't mean that we are actually in, you know,
harmony on the merits. Do you understand that?
>> Like when you say that, you're not being truthful. when
you say like uh well, you know, I misunderstood. No, no, no.
You twisted the words in a way that served you is what you did
and I won't accept anything less than that because there's no
way. There's no way. No way. >> Is that a pigeon? >> You
could misin >> uh it's not just one pigeon. It's multiple
pigeons. >> It doesn't even make sense. Unless you're disputing
the words I said. I literally said,
"Obviously, I want your life to have been saved, but sometimes
I wish it wasn't my actions that saved How does that anywhere
ever equate to so you wish I die? >> I mean, I could see
how somebody while I do think it's like fair that you're trying
to say you didn't say this, right? You're like trying to say,
"Oh, oh, I don't want you to take it this way." I get why it
feels unfair that she reacts, but there's a reason you said I
don't want you to take it this way,
So, I I understand both sid I'm remaining open to both sides
of this argument. Okay? >> Like, do you get that? Like,
you can't take that the wrong way. The very premise of the statement
implies that your life is saved. >> The the crappy thing
for me is I have so much context here that I'm not going to give
I can't really give Nick like a totally fair
shake in this argument cuz I've got so much context on their
previous arguments and how the relationship has gone up until
this
Like it's it's really rough cuz I don't know like does he think
what what other relationships has he ever had where he thinks
that like other people are logical all the time cuz we've seen
like pristine evidence literally video evidence that he is not
logical all the time. And so when like he debates his wife's
feelings all the time
and never like puts into the equation how emotional he can get
and how that distorts reality for him. It's like if he could
if he could treat his wife the way he treats himself in a conversation,
I think they'd have a lot of their problems solved. But I It's
just never going to happen, man. >> Why guy? Let's use
your version. Yes. If I encounter three armed guys and I save
my own life defending my house, still a hero. Take your [__]
out of your but yeah. Um Kate, would you like to address the
chat? Because
I'm down with
that explanation.
Like that doesn't chart reality to me. That does not chart reality
to me. To say that like I took it the wrong way. Kate's been
addressing the chat.
>> It's like, dude, what do you mean apparently you took
the wrong way? None of that could be taken that way because the
statement itself is referencing you being saved.
>> Don't take this the wrong way cuz I think you're attractive
no matter what, but you're getting fat as okay.
Don't wait. DON'T TAKE IT THOUGH. DON'T take it like as an insult.
It's Dude, it's so obvious that this doesn't work, right? It's
so so obvious that this doesn't work. I don't know why you'd
even attempt it. Why are we listening to Amaran's terrible husband?
Oh, cuz they had another massive crash out fight again. Okay,
so
we're checking it out. >> Wow. Crazy in the
>> We're getting the context as we lead into this. Okay.
>> What is your uh opinion on it, Kate? >> Let's
see if she answers.
>> Go for it. I'm not >> What does Kate have to say?
>> For me, this issue is not resolved unless
you're going to share with the class. Are you sticking with what
you said earlier? Ammo just wants Nick to her and be nice and
he can't do that. Yeah,
maybe. I get I get the feeling there's like something else there
that we're missing. There's got to be some more.
No, I
I don't know if this is true. Like Bucky,
I think there's something else going on there that is weird.
I don't think he's gay.
I don't think he's gay. I that I do think I get the impression
that she's the one who wants to be with him and he's the one
who is like resistant for some reason. But I mean lots of people
are like that. They just don't want to admit it, right? That
basically they need like the emotional state of the relationship
to be working to want to somebody.
It's like different. People think like, oh, I don't have to emotionally
like someone. I don't have to have an emotional connection with
someone to like them. And that's true. But the issue is if you
do have the emotional connection and then that gets like with
you no longer it like breaks
then that
with your like life you aren't going to somebody you don't like.
You're going to have a hard time doing that. Right. It is that
they can't have kids. Yeah. They can't have kids. Also leaked
by Nick >> cuz I'm not okay with that.
I'm not okay with you still claiming that you took it the wrong
way. No. What is What is wrong with you right now as you premised?
What the [__] are you talking about, bro? Why you
talking so weird? >> Wait, did we get that? I don't think
that went by yet. Hold on. I'm looking for it. No, it's going
to come through in just a second. I think >> I got the
chat logs. Oh, here it is. >> You said it after your statement.
So, it's not
>> water under the bridge as I premised.
Well, technically you said it's water under the bridge after
your first statement. So, it's not a premise. It's actually after
the fact. You didn't premise the statement with it. It wasn't
the premise. I think they mean premise as well. But Jesus,
why? Nick's such a debate, bro. It's crazy. >> Not premise.
What I said was premise. You see how like this is so twisted.
You're literally saying that like, well, even though I said the
thing after I've made my point. >> So now he's fighting
with the literal like verbatim language she used in the >> This
is a premise. It's like not really. But if you take it that way,
then certainly if I say something before my point, it's definitely
a premise, is it >> I think they mean preface. I made this
mistake earlier, too. To be like actually schizophrenic here,
to be actually like a I do believe they mean preface. Premise.
You can't really premise a statement. A statement can be made
on a premise or you could think something based on a premise,
but I don't think you premise a statement. You preface a statement.
Oh, well, you can you can make a statement under some premise.
Yeah. Okay.
Sorry. No more. No more. My point is that it absolutely
is the case that you in that moment for whatever reason right
maybe you weren't yourself maybe you were emotionally distressed
but there is no way >> oh she might have said promise >> that
I could have communicated more clearly what I had meant
the only alternative would be to not communicate what I meant
and what I was feeling because I I just don't understand how
someone can twist
me saying like as verbatim as I can It's not that I don't want
you to be saved because obviously I want you to be saved. It's
just sometimes I wish it wasn't me who saved you. That's literally
saying that like, you know, I wish a police officer had stepped
in.
>> Sometimes it's just like this performance art with this
bird landing on his head. >> Neighbor had had heard and
rushed over um whatever. Right.
>> Like like
>> sometimes I just wish it wasn't me who saved you.
But but to take that and say, "So you want me to die?" is like,
"I I don't see how you get there. I don't think it's possible
to get there." >> It's so easy. Or so it's so much easier
as a third party, but like I can obviously tell Nick saying this
like he feels like there's nothing there, but he doesn't even
remotely consider. I doubt I doubt he remotely considers how
Amaranth feels about getting saved. Like it's possible their
relationship wasn't doing that great before the the robbery,
right? like maybe there was stuff going bad before the robbery
and that she thought that that was like a clear indication that
he was still in love with her and like depending on how she took
that right then him saying I wish I wasn't the one who saved
you she might have had a whole bunch of things she was thinking
in her head that you just shattered right you might have actually
just [__] with your relationship majorly by saying
that so you could say oh don't take it this way
but I'm telling you there's a lot of other stuff that could be
going on in her head that would make that that statement like
kind of sting in a way that doesn't get saved by any preface
you make.
>> That's the part that I would like correct it. What do
you mean? But why?
I I was explaining to you guys because every time we I would
have preferred that alternative. Yeah. I mean, yes, but I just
feel like during our fight for you to question and say maybe
I do want you is like, okay, that's a whole like like it's one
thing to be like, my husband wishes he didn't save me, which
is already established to be untrue and could not be taken that
way. But it's like to go from my husband wish he didn't save
my life to my husband is plotting to kill me. You have to understand
that that is like
that's a whole another galaxy again, right?
Like it's like I would not have been nearly as troubled if you
had just been like
uh sorry Amaranth about 30 seconds ago says I would have preferred
that alternative, but I understand I ignored your premise and
was just immensely hurt. My bad. Okay, so she's literally trying
to deescalate. Oh, that's rough. >> What? You want me to
be safe? And left it there. But you went a step further and you
said >> taking a picture with the other phone every time
she chats. >> We I would have preferred that alternative.
Yeah. I mean, yes, but I just feel like during our fight for
you.
>> Sorry, I was looking at my other monitor and listening.
>> That's a whole like like it's one thing to be like my
husband wishes he didn't save me, which is already established
to be untrue. >> It's also just weird cuz this is right
Like literally there's just a website for this
>> true cannot be taken that way. But it's like to go from
my husband wish he didn't save my life to my husband is plotting
to kill me. You have to understand that that is like
That's a whole another galaxy again, right?
Like it's like I would not have been nearly as troubled if you
had just been like, "What? I you didn't want me to be saved and
left it there." But you went a step further and you said, "I
don't know. I could see you wanted me." It's like you realize
that saying that is what gave Ryan the ammunition to follow
that motion with the court, right? That statement did it. Oh,
there was literally a motion with the court. I see. Oh, he was
actually talking about a court case. Oh, that's my bad earlier.
If Nick ever watches this, I didn't realize there was an actual
motion filed with the court. Okay. >> I don't know if you
ever like >> that must have been something like a restraining
order. >> Well, a Twilight joke doesn't do it. Um, my husband
being super strong and resembling a vampire doesn't do it. Do
you know what causes someone to have the ammunition to file that
with a court? It would be a statement such as my husband wants
me.
That is the one. It's like that's why I was like so confused
and like I think we shouldn't mince words about it here. Okay.
Again,
I said a statement with a premise, you ignore the premise. It's
like that's like
but it's like, you know, it can happen.
But to jump again to you don't want me to be saved. Okay, that's
a jump. But like again, sure, emotions are high, but then to
jump again to be I could see you wanting me, it's like, okay,
never did I say anything that could be interpreted that way.
You understand that? Like when someone says that like that has
major ramifications both socially and legally, right? Like you
can't just say I could see my spouse wanting me and like that's
the >> All right, there's a chatter named Darius didn't
do it. You're repeating the same sentence again and again. That
is also true. Darius didn't do it. Sorry, I just thought it was
funny that that's clearly it's referring to Darius, like actual
Darius. >> That's funny. That name. Yeah, that is a smart
name to get. Okay. It's It's literally useful for every single
occasion. Dary's always being accused of doing so he did. >> No,
it's not a weird thing to say to my wife because the context
is that every time I try to say, "Hey, can we talk about this?"
Referring to an issue that we were experiencing concurrently,
she would say, "It's not worth it. You saved my life." Do you
not understand that?
That's a weird thing to say. You see, you're assuming that what
I said is the first peculiar thing. Not understanding that peculiar
things beget peculiar things. I mean, imagine that, right? Like
it doesn't even have to be saved your life. It's like let's say
um I don't know
>> when he says that oh it's not when she says that it's
not worth it you saved my life to me what I would immediately
think if I heard that as a third party is
she is suspicious of you or or upset with you over something
right like she's
she's feeling negative feelings about you and she's trying to
say so Nick might see this through the lens of his own issues
but I think she's also trying to say like I think there are things
I want to say to you right now that you get very upset but I'm
not going to because you saved my life. That's what I hear when
I hear that statement. I don't know if he I can't tell if he's
hearing the same thing cuz he's not really described the issue.
He says something we're both suffering through concurrently.
I don't know if she's dismissing that issue or if she's saying
that like while thinking about the other issue she has. >> Uh
your spouse uh saved you the last pizza last piece of pizza.
She goes, "Oh, there's one more piece of pizza, but you can have
it." Could you imagine if she goes, "Hey, um I feel like we're
not communicating very well. Can we talk about it?" And then
you go, "It's not worth it. you saved me the last piece of pizza.
You'd be like, "Okay."
Yeah. So, what I hear there is she's like she's like sort of
conceding the argument in a way. Sorry. With her original statement,
not what he just said. She's like basically conceding that argument.
She doesn't want to have that argument. She's like, "You can
just whatever way you want it because I'm like trying to make
up for this thing that happened and like I don't want I don't
want to say the bad things, man. There's like a couple different
things going on here." Well, we'll see. I'm sure it'll come out
as we go through. Also, yeah, I'm sure he could get poop on his
head. I'm sure he has gotten Has he not gotten his head pooped
on yet?
Really? Is there really not a clip of him streaming? He streamed
so many times with these birds out. Was he like get them to go
to the bathroom and then pull them out? I actually have no idea.
How does he avoid the the poop on his head conundrum? But why
does that mean we can't talk about it? Cuz it pales in comparison
to you giving me that last piece of pizza.
Eventually, you get to the point where you're like, "Well, sometimes
I wish you hadn't given me that pizza because then we could talk
about these things." Now, you've entered my mindset. I was like,
"Listen, you keep saying I saved your life. It's like a chant
at this point. Can we like dispense with that just for a second
and talk?" And you'd be like, "No, it's not that important. You
saved my life. That's the important part."
You're demeing every, you know, attempt at communication I made.
And so, of course, I'm going to in exasperation, I'm be like,
you know, it's not even a question. I want your life saved. >> It's
just sometimes. And sometimes being times when you're demeing
talking about the issues
>> sometimes I wish it wasn't me >> so that you couldn't
say that. Zero Addie. I don't know how to put that in any more
blunt of a way. >> Okay, we're coming up to another message
from her right away.
Sorry. I You have to understand with these fights, they're going
to reference every single element of what was said on this stream
like a hundred times over a 4-hour fight or something. Okay?
So, while you may not appreciate me going over that context now
that it's like slow and it's a slow burn and we're building up,
you will very much appreciate it once we're an hour from now
and they're screaming about like vampires and [__]
and you have an idea of what's going on. Okay? Cuz otherwise
you'd have no [__] idea what she what this guy means
when when he's screaming about vampires. Okay? I wish you could
just come clean about that part. It's like I understand all of
the the the taking things
in a way that they could not be taken, but that's a jump. >> Uh
she does respond to just come clean. >> It is jump to the
level where words start to lose all meaning.
Because I mean you could be like, well, technically anyone could
want to keep anyone. I could see the motive. It's like, dude,
okay, stop then. Then that that's meaningless statement,
I know you said you took it wrong, but I'm saying that even if
he took that wrong, it is another galaxy, if not universe, to
take my husband, which is a
my husband. Let's Oh, man. Cuz I He's going the wrong direction.
I thought what she took wrong. I thought what he was mad about
was the fact that she wouldn't communicate. If he just goes and
says he's mad about the statement again, then he's kind of just
lying about what he's or he doesn't know what he's upset about.
my husband says he wish he didn't save me. That's not even
that. It's another thing to say on stream
basically knowing that you're sending the clip to your lawyer,
which you did. It's another thing to say on stream in front of,
I don't know, 7,000 people,
and then send the clip to your lawyer that I could see my husband
wanting me
Can you see how even if I had said I wish I didn't save you,
that does not mean I wish I had you. That is a >> I think
she definitely accepts that now >> level of commission.
Do you not understand the difference or or do you? >> Everyone
understands the difference, but she's going to have like some
she's going to have something here or she might have something
here where she's going to have some emotion tied to this conversation
and she's going to want to make her point too. And she could
concede this. I don't know if she'll concede this first. I'm
guessing she's going to want to talk about whatever her emotional
thing is. Dude, he waits so long for her to take to talk back.
No, I'm not in a loop. I'm trying to explain it slightly differently
to get the point across because >> I'm not looping. You're
looping. >> She's either avoiding the issue or she's actually
not understanding. And I'm going to take the more charitable
view, which is that she's not understanding. Like, I mean, what
do you do when you're talking to someone and they keep missing
what you're saying?
>> Like she says, I said I took it the wrong way. It's
like, yeah, no, I understand that and I accept that. >> She
just dropped a big message. We'll see if he reads that >> for
me. But like, you got to admit that like someone saying they
wish they didn't save your life, which is not what I said, but
someone saying that is not writ large for you to accuse them
of plotting to have you killed.
>> Dude, there's no way. Did he just miss >> the
entire thing? >> Can you Can you see that?
>> That is like more. >> Also, Tequila Sunset, are
you like up with the stream? What are you? This guy is talking
about crazy.
>> His talk with Ethan was way less hostile than people
made it out to be. Sounds like Hassan's underwater. You're You're
like way behind or something. This guy's way behind. >> We're
going to reach that just lying. >> I don't know if he saw
her message. I might have to read it myself. you retreating to
a place where you know language is basically meaningless and
you go well you know it's not uh a jump because I could see a
reason anyone could want any other person killed is the only
real defense in which case it's like sure but why are you expressing
on stream and then think you're aware >> okay I'll hold
on we'll see if he's going to read it here or not another message
shortly after not really nope >> I don't understand
I mean
>> okay when I was in a bad state of mind saying you wished
you hadn't saved me sounds like I messed up an inside job and
I was supposed to die in my room. Obviously, I don't think that
now, and I was just tripping on trauma and her feelings,
dude. She
I feel like Amaranth gets such a bad rap, and she does such a
good job of communicating what's upsetting her. And
like that, it's literally exactly what I said it was going to
be. It's literally exactly the thing I said,
except she's actually handling it better than I assumed she would.
I thought she would like basically not be able to say like, "Oh,
well, like it's difficult to make a concession when you have
like a strong emotion tied to some event, right?" But she's just
like, "Yeah, I don't think that um I was really up." Like, how
does a conversation even go past that of her being like, "Yeah,
I was reallyed up. Sorry."
She's already the person that was violated. He started leaking
stuff out of nowhere, right?
And she's the person who's been violated and she goes, "Hey,
like I was in a bad state of mind. I don't really think that.
I'm sorry that that happened." I guess it's like fine crime novellas.
But like, bro, what the mother that extended magazines, they
had the gun to your head. What are you talking about? They messed
it up. That's just them not doing it. But also, why would you
think if I was plotting an inside job and those >> Yeah,
this isn't I think she understands that it's not logical, Nick.
She understands. She understands. She understands. She's like
literally She literally just said, "Hey, I was in a bad state
of mind. I don't think that anymore. This is what I thought."
But like when I was in a bad state of mind, when I wasn't thinking
correctly,
when I wasn't thinking correctly, saying you hadn't, you wish
you hadn't saved me. Sounds like I messed up a sad job. She's
like saying, "This is a delusion. This is wrong. I know this
is wrong. I can identify that this is wrong." And he's he's just
like not listening. Someone said, "Is he like intentionally trying
to Britney Spears?" I don't know. He's like, "I don't think so.
I think this has to be pathology on his part. I don't think it's
like intentional. It has to be pathology because somebody who's
intentional about this would just be more calculated. We'd be
like way less transparent, way less like in the public with it.
If you were trying to actually do some here,
right? If you were some kind of calculated like conniving evil
genius here, trying to make her like spiral and have a meltdown
or something, you would do it. You wouldn't do it in the public
eye like this where you look like the complete villain.
I'm pretty sure. Maybe >> they messed it up. A did I know
they messed it up? B. If I knew they messed it up, then my plan
is to go my co-conspirators, but them in such a way that it was
measured and controlled because my priority was not to hit you.
Oh, wait. >> Yeah, she already she literally conceded that
it it didn't happen. This isn't the thing. That it was irrational.
>> He's just talking.
Yeah, >> we already heard this one, Nick. >> One
stone. >> We looping, Nick. >> Like, it doesn't make
sense to be like, and he gerely, you know, was very careful to
take only control. >> Next bit. Next bit. >> No,
we had panic room. I could have gone in and locked myself in
and they' never get to me. That's the thing I'm saying. It's
like I chose a course of action and I chose engagement.
I didn't have to choose engagement. There's two easy ways I could
have chose not engagement. >> There's no way that she just
blows him the out here.
>> This is actually so >> that like it is unfair.
>> You are you are arguing logic.
You're literally arguing logic right now. You're literally arguing
logic, Nick.
You're arguing logic when I already said I understand it. Uh,
and it was a bad Well, I already said I understand and it was
a bad state of mind. I What What more needs to be done here?
The argument is over. You won. You literally your point has been
made. She agrees with you. She understands. >> It is a
untrue statement to say that especially in the context to 7,000
people then sending the video to your lawyer saying that I could
see my husband plotting to have me. That's an untrue statement.
If they're not supposed to be talking about each other, is it
worse that he is talking about her or that she is interacting
with him in his chat?
Um, I mean, I'm I assume in my
so I you said in the eyes of a judge, I don't technically know,
but I'm like 95% sure that it would be the same thing for me,
which is who opened this line of communication? Who was talking
about this first? Who brought it up? In which case, this is Nick.
>> That wasn't the state of psychosis.
I mean, I feel like in a state of psychosis, you're not cogent
enough to be like, and I got to send this to my lawyer immediately
to be used. I don't think that's how that works.
>> Uh, that could easily be how that works. >> If
you're thinking of a legal maneuver, then you're probably not
in a state of >> I mean,
I Dude, what? His mind doesn't allow it itself to feel closure
because he doesn't think anything has changed as a result of
her conceding, which goes back to the whole, "Well, then you
just got to leave thing." Yeah. basically like
I it's it's super telling that he
is bringing this up
right in the middle of saying that they're in the best place
they've ever been in in like forever. Maybe the best place in
their relationship ever. And he's like, but also I'm going to
start talking about this stuff,
right?
Like if you can't be okay and be letting this stuff go when you're
at like the height of how things are going.
Again, I think I I pointed this out though. That's why I was
like, "Oh, I don't know if
I don't know if this relationship could survive streaming cuz
everybody's going to consistently pick at their relationship
because it's already been content on stream." And so, I don't
know how you survive that. Like, like, you feel genuinely up
about this. You feel genuinely upset about this still. Even though
she's she's said she's sorry, she wasn't thinking correct. She
doesn't believe that anymore, right?
She said all of this and you still can't let it go. That's That's
rough. And then people are going to bring it up all the time.
Oh man, I don't know how you >> activating the strategic
part of your
>> Arty Epstein, thank you for the 21 months. People I
like people in psychosis are capable of planning and doing things.
They're not like they're not like brain broken entirely. They
I feel like psychosis is like delusions and stuff, right? Like
you are probably feeling like delusions. You're not adhering
to reality. It doesn't mean your entire brain doesn't work. It
doesn't mean you can't like do cause and effect. It means that
there's some part of your reality that is like discorded. Some
part of your your version of reality in your brain is like slightly
off from actual reality or maybe significantly off, but it's
like it's almost [clears throat] always localized. It's almost
never just everything is off in every possible way.
Ironically, the bird did see it all cuz the birds were flying
around my room
the night of the
They literally saw everything. >> Seen everything. It's
also partly why I'm not as scared of beon doing something nuts
if I'm shooting fireworks because she didn't do something nuts
when I shot a gun. >> Okay, so from here there's at some
point later on she says check your phone. So we'll see. >> I'm
just saying, >> oh wow, there's like a big break here.
So we start here. The actual fight is here with the like darkened
camera. So he walks up to like the bedroom. So she's already
said like, I wondered why you weren't coming coming to bed. I
guess you're like streaming or whatever and I guess you're talking
about me. So, we'll have to find the good place to cut over.
He goes outside to fire some some >> I don't know. It It's
It's hard for me to to to see it as just Oh, I misunderstood
when it felt like the thing was farmed.
[clears throat] You stated it in front. >> Wait, are there
Corvid people? Aren't Corvids um like ravens? Crows ravens?
Are there people who keep those like as pets? as many people
as possible. >> And then you try to calcify by >> having
your lawyer
make sure that he got the clip and then that very lawyer went
and filed something with the court that would be leaning on that
assertion that was untrue that you made
to do legal action.
I feel like that
is the part that is a fabrication of the truth and then using
it in a pretty self-s serving way. Like you realize that, right?
Like when you said, "Oh, I didn't realize they're following emotion."
It's like you gave them It's like you're sitting there handing
someone a bullet to put in a gun and you go, "Well, I didn't
realize he was going to put the bullet in the gun."
What do you think the guy holding the gun reaching his hand out
for the bullet is
You know, you gave it to a lawyer who's paid to do stuff on billable
hours. He's gonna do stuff. Do you get that? >> What could
possibly go wrong, Marty? >> Like, it's like putting a
fox in the hen house and saying, "I didn't know he's gonna eat
the the chickens." It's like, I don't think that is a valid defense
for the action. I mean, let me ask you in another tact, what
were you hoping for him to do with that clip? >> Uh, when
her mind state was broken, when she was having like delusional
thoughts, she probably hoped that he was going to get some kind
of restraining order to keep her safe.
But she doesn't think that anymore. And she says she was wrong
for thinking that. She was wrong.
I'm back to doing Nick. I'm back in the nicely loop me >> if
you cannot see that >> chubby bird >> because that
tells me that it could happen again >> here. I don't think
she she doesn't respond for quite a while and then he's going
to keep talking.
>> I I just want
it can be resolved. Like I understand that that was a avoidable
and
difficult to fathom misunderstanding. The part about saying,
"Oh, well, despite you saying, you know, you definitely want
me to be saved." That's what I said. I said, "I definitely want
you to be saved." >> I just wish
Okay. Okay. I see. Plotting. Cuz not defensible thing would be
to accuse me of of trying to get her. Yeah. >> Yeah. That's
like the ninth time. Definitely. Like four loops ago, he said
he wasn't looping, by the way. Like four loops ago, he was like,
"I'm definitely not looping, guys." Doesn't >> even make
any sense. It's actually crazy that this guy might get popular
enough and get a big enough audience that they will gaslight
him into believing that all of these like of his own like delusions
are true. I do think he's entertaining so he can get like an
audience, [cough]
but
man, it's going to it's got to be somebody's job to just keep
this guy tethered to reality. This gets this gets pretty goofy.
Okay. Usually has 1K. I mean, he's got around 1K right now, doesn't
he? Yeah, he's got around 1K right now. This 5,000 is we're on
the VOD. So the 5,000 is the views for the >> Bro, an altered
state of mind does not mean [clears throat] you later then when
cogent send it as evidence. You see how maybe
well that's the problem with delusions like this is
you need to I like I would assume you would need to find ways
to work through them that they may be persisting,
right? that like when things are bad, when bad things happen,
they're more likely just like when something bad happens to Nick
and he goes back to like, "Oh, do you remember what happened
in March of 2022?" The Dobby, that's the Dobby event, by the
way. I think it's March 2022. I can't remember for sure, but
and then he what's the other one? He does that one and now he's
doing this one, right? Like when something bad happens, he'll
go back to spinning and spiraling on his own negative thoughts.
She's doing the same thing except she happens to go back to spiraling
on something that's a delusional thought. And so probably you're
never going to be totally through that, right? October 22. Thank
you.
You're probably never going to be totally through that. You'll
have to understand she's going to feel paranoid um as a result
of like that traumatic event where she got her head rocked like
multiple times. She's going to be paranoid, man. It's going to
You got to again,
you just got to figure out if you can handle that.
>> They need a They just need literally a therapist is
ideal. nifty hotel calendar. They just need a third party who
can be like the touchstone and
like help them figure out cuz they both have unfortunately for
Nick like Amaran's not the only one who has some like borderline
delusional thoughts.
If it's not if it's not pathological for Nick, he's like a total
psychopath. So I he we watched him say that Amaranth assaulted
him and then we got to see the clip of her basically like doing
nothing and him freaking the out, right? If there was only one
delusional part party here, like it would be one thing, but there
are two delusional parties here, right? Or hypothetically, I
guess. I don't actually know that about Amaranth. It could be
him kind of gaslighting. So maybe he is a vampire. Who knows?
But you need a third party to be that touchstone between the
two of you. >> It was an ultra state of mind. Look, I I
have a lot of the reason why I know it's not, you know, just
that.
The reason why I know that it was planted to have teeth as a
legal maneuver is because she did the same thing with that whole
about how oh the the the contracts that I was coerced into signing.
It's like my god.
Are you [__] serious? That is never >> Dude,
I we had a whole litigation session on this one with Nick on
the stream, too.
Like
I explained to him I'm like, "Bro, just explain to me like who's
getting way more money out of this." And like he's like, "Yeah,
yeah. I guess like the stuff I'm getting is like worth way more
technically, but like it's not guaranteed or something." And
I'm like, "Okay, but like you have to understand that when you're
getting her to take her horses as as like um it's like, "Oh,
you're you get your horses, I get my watches." It's like, "Bro,
your watches are insanely expensive."
He's like, "Yeah, but the value for them could go to zero." It's
like, but is it going to these like random collector watches
you have? Probably not, right? It's not that. It's not coercion
technically. It's just like he's taking advantage in a way that
he probably shouldn't be taking advantage that she should have
her own lawyer. And I don't think she had her own lawyer. I think
they were both going through the same lawyer. And it felt like
he was taking a little bit of advantage. Maybe in a way that's
plausibly deniable, but
>> and then it became a whole well like uh you know um
he he knew more about the contract. It's like because I read
it and I gave it to you to read, but I guess you didn't read
it. But that's not my fault. When I say sign it, I go read it
and if you think it's fine, sign it. It's literally what I said
every time. I have literally never been like, "You should sign
this. This is good if you sign it." No, I've only ever been like,
"Read it and if you think it's good, sign it." Like, it's it's
literally fully balls in your court. The only thing is that I've
said, "I've read it. I think it's fine. You read it. If you think
it's fine, sign it." That's always how it goes.
Did you just sniff his bird? By the way,
did I just watch him sniff that bird? >> I've only ever
been like, "It's literally what I said every time. I have literally
never been like, "You should sign this. This is good. If you
sign it, no, I've only ever been like, read it. If you think
it's good, sign it." >> I think it's right here. Did I
slow down at the right time? Maybe not. Yeah. >> Like it's
>> Dude, you hear the inhale. You hear him >> It's
literally fully balls and
I've only ever been like, "Read it and if you think it's good,
sign it." Like
>> maybe that's the echo of his footstep. Maybe that's
the echo of his footstep.
literally fully balls in your >> It still looked like it
though,
man.
The only thing is that I've said I've read it. I think it's fine.
You read it. If you think it's fine, sign it. That's always how
it goes.
that could be fair maybe. But I would say probably there's some
other things going on here. Like are you the one who normally
like evaluates these documents and business agreements for Amaranth
and signs them? Are you like the person who usually does that?
Maybe because of a conflict here, given it's your asset division
in the event of a divorce, that maybe she should have her own
counsel for this and they should be advising her directly and
it's probably worth however many, you know, like $5,000 or something
out of your multi-million like your tens of million dollar estate
to just make sure she's not getting screwed over, right? She
should have her own advocate in the situation,
right? Probably makes sense. >> So, like, okay, fine. Alter
state of mind that day, but then on another day saying that I
coerced her into signing her contracts. Well, that's what is
that then? That's a that's a legal maneuver, right? And >> the
[__] >> And then you thought you had done something
because then you went up there and you go, "Uhhuh." You see,
now I have >> Is he getting alimony? Oh, I think I wrote
this down at the time, but I don't know if I'd ever be able to
find the notepad. Hold on.
I think I wrote it down and then I didn't um I don't think I
ever saved the notepad here. Let me see. Let me see. Let me see.
Let me see. Wait, what was this? Okay. No. No. No. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm looking I'm looking
through my notepads, my personal notepads to see if I can find
where I wrote this [__] down. Um, no, I don't have
it here.
Maybe I wrote it in a Google doc. [clears throat] I can't
>> It was like um it was roughly 50/50 asset splits and
then it was 50-50 asset splits on most things and then they got
to pick like the specific things they wanted. So, they did like
a 50-50 split and the specific things she wanted were her pets
and the specific thing Nick wanted was millions of dollars in
>> What you have is you saying something in a video without
any confirmation. Like, that's not evidence.
I could make a video right now and say something that's untrue.
It doesn't make it evidence. Like, do you want me to say it right
now? Something that's untrue? It's like, dude, it doesn't make
it evidence. It literally doesn't make it evidence.
Just because it was said on a live stream, especially if it's
said by the party
Um, it probably is evidence actually >> asserting it. He
doesn't make it evidence, but it sure does.
>> Yeah, cars and watches weren't splitable assets and
then like the cars and watches were all his and then the horses
were whatever. Yeah, he was going to get 50% from their their
company going >> Making billable hours. Let me tell you
about that.
>> Lawyer made a lot of money from it. >> Those horses
could be worth a lot of crazy cash to be fair. Yeah, but like
one of his watches is worth like 600 grand or like like I think
he has million-dollar watches, too. He's got like crazy designer
watches that are like 101 or 105 models. >> So So you're
saying she magically just has psychosis every time she's, you
know, trying to legally maneuver for an outcome, huh? Is that
is that the is that the take? >> No, you've described other
time I I don't want to know this. I shouldn't know this, but
you've described other times she's had psychosis, Nick, where
she's not been maneuvering for anything.
Why did you explain to me why she was rapturing? How she was
rapturing 80 different times? How was How was she using that
one? >> Is that Is that the inside take? Well, no. Like,
like look, the the the truth is like it's obvious, right? Like
it's like it was a maneuver, right? And I feel like part of it
is like if you can admit that that's a maneuver, then at least,
you know, we can agree to like not do that anymore, right? like
we can agree not to do it anymore. But if you're like, "Oh yeah,
no, I was in an altered state." Okay. So you're saying that in
a future altered state, you will also be planting things to try
and use as a legal maneuver.
Well, I dude, the altered states may be connected,
right? The altered states may be like the same delusion that
she's experiencing at a different time. So if she was experiencing
a delusion of you being a vampire and being a threat to her and
then she's feeling better, he doesn't think anything of it. And
then she's later experiencing that same delusion of being under
threat, that you're a vampire, that she feels like threatened,
that she's in danger. Then she might use the evidence of the
previous time in a state of like in a delusional state to go
and file some paperwork or get somebody to file >> cuz
that's not that's not a tenable situation for me. Like that's
not a tenable situation for me. >> Um I actually have no
problem with Nick getting 50% of this relationship. I basically
the problem was that he was basically guaranteeing he was getting
it significantly more than 50%. which was weird, right? That's
all. And that basically he was giving her her animals and making
that explicit, not really making it explicit the current dollar
values of the split that was happening that like he was probably
getting significantly more and he was using his position as the
person who had always managed their money, who had always signed
their contracts and looked over everything to tell her that this
was good and then she didn't get her own lawyer to look over
it. Right. And I do understand how when you just say, "Well,
this will make sure your horses are safe because Nick had had
done something akin to threatening the animals, which she's done
multiple times, and then he says he didn't do, right?
So, in those cases, like she probably just was going to sign
to get her horses, right? To guarantee she's going to get her
horses. Okay, we're going to start skipping forward a little
bit more cuz he's looping a lot
>> disgusting. I'd like to talk about it. Really, really,
>> he just shot his fence.
>> He's just missed really badly.
>> Band that guy, too. >> He's not even riding the
horse. leaking >> He's so Mongolian he can't even an arrow
without being on a horse of some kind. Okay. He's He's literally
No, no, no. He's got the seat still. Okay. He's got the seat
still,
but he's just not riding. He's so Mongolian he becomes more accurate
once he's on that horse that's riding up and down. >> His
ears is starting to smell. All right. Who else? Just raise your
hand. We'll get it over with. Dreamer.
Oh. >> Conflict is kind of what you want to do.
>> All right. All right. All right, we're going to keep
going forward a little >> You know, maybe open the door
sequel, right? Your queen will never love you. >> Sorry.
When you talk to the Sims, it's very funny. >> How's it
feel knowing
that no matter how a partner I am, your queen will never love
you.
>> That's such a huge W.
I could I could do anything I want to this, she'll never like
you like she likes me.
[laughter] Is he high, by the way? I feel like he's high or something.
What's the time stamp on this part? I don't know. 9324.
He's like drowsy as I guess he's he's 9 hours into a stream.
This is how I'd look 9 hours into a stream. But >> there's
a sale going on on her only fans. You can find the love there.
>> But don't forget I get 50%. >> Unless you run
out of money, in which case the love will be on pause until your
next paycheck. >> And now he's Now he's just winning. >> There's
a RM watch I would like to buy. Yeah, he was taking gummies for
one of their first arguments at some point. Yeah, I don't know
if he's doing that >> No, [clears throat] excuse me.
Excuse you.
I'm not being mean. I'm offering a
Are you talking about?
>> Business, business, business.
Okay, let's keep going forward a little bit. Okay. All right.
This is where he finally goes to head upstairs and talk to Amarath.
Okay.
We're finally here, guys. Oh, I should say, hold on.
We're two subs away from another hour on the stream right now,
guys. We need that extra hour. So, let's load it up now cuz we're
they're about to start the fight and I do not want Well, I'm
I'm never going to cut the stream during the fight. We probably
get through it anyway, but you should add more time. Okay. Thank
you.
you like to talk about it? >> I do remember that Stella
sloth. It was
>> I said, "Would you like to talk about
>> Talk about what?
Do you think she
I feel like
it's possible that she was just watching the whole time,
but I think it's crazy to walk up here live when she's in bed
like sound sleepy
and just be like, "Do you want to talk about it?" without saying
you're live. You're like in the dark. Is he hiding? He's streaming.
[sighs]
>> Matt, thank you for the tune.
No, I understand you didn't mean that.
That was
>> right. But I'm just saying that like it's one thing
to be like, okay, I misunderstood that even though
>> uh twisted rope, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's
go. >> You explained it. But it's another to then jump
further
to
Oh, I don't know. um telling 7,000 people in a very compelling
fashion,
right, that you think it's very likely
that I would do that
>> a lot of stuff you don't mean to the to >> Yeah,
but the difference is I didn't accuse you of
it would be like me saying >> I I straight up think Nick
is worse than most of those arguments. I feel like Nick Nick
leaks things that are real and hurtful, right? And Amaranth is
like, "I think you're trying to get me killed." And it's like,
we could all tell that Nick's probably not trying to get her
killed. Okay. Like, it sounds like she's speaking from a totally
emotional place. He's speaking from a like I'm going to I'm going
to leak our address right now. I'm going to leak our door code
to get in here. It's like totally different. >> You know
what? I noticed that you also want me like >> I don't want
to be content for you right now. I'm trying to sleep. I'm naked.
Yeah, but you came into my chat, so like that's moot. >> I
came to see what you were doing and then you >> you commented
in my chat. >> Can you Can you stop? I said I came to see
what you're doing, but you haven't come to bed. >> This
is some hardcore
Darvo [__] right now. My god, you came into my chat
while I was leaking things about you while I was talking about
your psychosis. You came into my chat while I was talking about
your mental health. That's what you did. >> You commented
in the chat. I understand what you're saying. >> You're
ranting about me. It's like, can we not do that?
>> and I told you you were act like I was going crazy because
I thought you were a vamper. I told you my brain broke at the
time. I was not thinking right. And the catalyst for that was
that comment, but I understand I misunderstood it. It's all I
was saying.
>> Do you understand that when you say you misunderstood
it, it begets
>> I would forgive her if she was plotting on him right
now. Okay. She was plotting how to have some people break in
for crypto in the opposite direction right now. I would forgive
her cuz this is it's actually crazy. Yeah, Nick, you were right
about everything.
Well, you see how when you say certain things, it feels bad for
me.
>> everything that I actually said like you took from it
exactly what you wanted to take from it. >> I didn't. It's
very hurtful and took from like the most hurtful thing. Can >> Can
you not understand something? Like it's like
if I Are you disputing the fact that >> you don't argue?
I already told you I understand that you don't convince. >> I
think we can continue to be calm here and just talk about it.
>> Well, you
>> dude like Nick gaslights me into thinking that Amaran's
a worse communicator than she is. He is so bad at listening that
he gaslights me into thinking that she doesn't express herself
well. She's literally expressed herself perfectly like multiple
times in this night to deescalate this situation and say like
literally I think he was doing the wrong thing and she tried
to deescalate. She tried to go oh no I know why you're mad but
like please don't talk about this stuff and
I like I but he is so incapable of hearing it that I'm actually
I'm I'm actually like losing it.
Someone hit up this guy with a TLDDR >> home and then come
in here when I'm sleeping with your stream.
What? >> You you you you [snorts] came into my stream and
commented, "You're just ranting about me, dude. I told you. Please
stop talking about me all the time for your content. You touch
your head. Can you stop,
Oh, she's never going to win. Literally, everybody everybody
in his chat is just going to they're going to hear hear this
register of this tone, this register, and they're going to go
this stupid [__] [__] THIS.
There's going to be so many people who will just lose their minds
the second they hear her talking with this like exact register.
This this like note she hits. They'll lose it.
>> You're justing about me. I told you please stop talking
about me all the time for your content. You said you would. Can
you stop?
I have absolutely
withheld
the that's actually
Let's just keep it at that.
But the things that I'm talking about all happened on stream
and so there's not really that much secret if someone was even
around from that time.
You understand that, right? >> That's not the point. >> There's
stuff that no one knows. >> You think our drama is >> Oh,
that's not the point of it. I I feel like you're not You're not
understanding
Stop. Please.
Like at this point it gets just super
dude it just it's so
it's crazy that he's sitting here she's literally saying stop
please don't please stop please stop streaming please stop using
me for drama on your stream and he's sitting here like well you
see I know you apologize but the thing is about how You apologized.
>> I understand that you're saying that you were seeing
what I was up to and you were in in stream, but
if you want to talk to me about it, let's be honest, you could
text me,
but you talk
Dude. [laughter]
>> Yeah, I know. I'm discussing incredibly personal [__]
about you on my live stream. Do you think if you wanted to get
mad at me, do you think you could just text me [laughter] >> to
chat?
>> Because you wanted to call you. >> You didn't
answer me. That's why I went to your stream.
>> When did you try calling me? >> Before I even
talked in your chat. You did not answer. >> I I because
I was talking and I >> Then how am I supposed to talk to
you? No. Can I okay?
>> Actually, actually, don't come in my chat and if you
call and I don't answer and I just keep talking about you. Um,
don't do anything. Just just lay there and tell. >> You
keep interrupting me. So, like, do you actually want me to answer
the question or you just trying to interrupt me, [laughter]
Oh, it's so
She's literally crying. And this guy is like, "Well, you keep
interrupting me, so I wasn't >> How am I supposed to talk
to you? Don't
>> You keep interrupting me. So, like, do you actually
want me to answer the question or are you just trying to interrupt
me?"
>> Either is fine because like I don't want to answer something
you don't care
>> This is not resolving things on your
>> Okay. I don't think it's anything like
I I want to make a joke.
POV, you're dating Pisco. I I would imagine this is a little
bit similar. OKAY. BUT NOT ACTUALLY THE SAME. I DOUBT HE'S anywhere
near I don't actually think so. It's just like a joke cuz it's
like the same sort of like
>> Please stop. >> I'm going to explain this. >> Like
the last time when you said I >> don't think he's abusive.
I just I I I'm sorry I had to say it cuz it is just very funny.
>> And then you unmuted it without telling >> This
is not like that at all. This is not like that at all. >> I
don't want to do this on stream. Can you stop? >> I I I
I need to explain something real fast. Just so we're >> off
stream later. [laughter] >> No, I'm saying this is just
so for future reference. Okay,
>> Just like how the open the door thing started because
I don't think I did anything wrong. I just said, "Hey, could
you do this thing for me?" And then you decided to call in
and try to paint a certain picture. You weren't communicating
with me. Okay, that was to paint a picture and to talk to my
chat. That's weird. >> I'm not painting any pictures. >> I'm
not saying can I can I can I finish,
Hold on. Somebody said relevant meme for stream. Give me a second.
Wait, why did this go? OH, YEAH.
YOU'RE NOT MAKING YOU [screaming]
>> YOU'RE NOT MAKING [screaming] SENSE. YOU
certified classic. He's got the Hutch faces.
Bisco and Hutch at the same time. It's crazy. >> At the
time, in that instance, you were correct.
There's no way you're going to [__] say no on that
one.
>> Well, picture with a I don't >> No, no, no.
Now, now you want to attack the expression. Sure. um you were
more so communicating to my chat with that statement than to
me. And if you want to dispute that, we can listen to what you
said because it wasn't addressed to me. >> Revisiting old
>> No, no. I'm I'm trying to I'm trying to make a point
here. My point is that like
going forward, if you want it to stay
chat or off stream,
don't talk about it in chat. Don't call me when I'm streaming.
>> You know,
>> this guy is hardcore gaslighting right now. Blaming
her for this. >> And and and can I can I can I can I can
I can I can I can I can I can I can I can I finish? Can I finish
the The difference is this. Okay. I told you I was on speaker
phone because my hands were full and I was trying to do >> What?
You didn't even answer your phone >> No, no, no. Not today.
I'm saying back then. Like you interrupted me when I was talking
about back then. I literally said back then you were talking
to my chat because I told you you're on speaker phone because
my hands were busy
and you just started talking to my chat. That's my point. I'm
saying like calling
You're referencing a different situation than the current one.
I feel bad for but I really wish I could see Nick emoting while
he gaslights her. Every time she like tries to get a word in,
he just like makes a hutch face at the camera. Okay. [laughter]
Sorry, I wanted to answer this Asian mock question. It was uh
right here. Oh, whoops. Is this how they talk to each other before
the divorce and drama? They debate on all the time. I mean, I
don't believe that Nick's ever not talked like this as an adult.
I feel like Nick has been this person in every conversation he's
ever been in the entire time he's been an adult. There's just
no other explanation for the level of autism we see. It has to
be pathological.
It has to be. Um, with Amarant, I really don't know. This has
been their dynamic for as long as we've been aware of it. >> Being
on stream is fine. that doesn't warrant sharing stuff. But if
you call me and I tell you you're you're on speaker phone and
you continue, then that's obviously public record, right? That's
that's in the public at that point. If you type in my chat, it's
also same thing. You could, you know, we're pretending like we
don't have solutions here, but you could just say, "Hey, can
you check your phone in chat?" And then everyone let me know
and I would check,
right? Like that's the that's the actual solution to make a long
paragraph is always about talking to chat, not to me. Let's be
honest.
>> Well, you know, at that point now I see you're still
talking about me at nasty doctor today. It's like I'm a little
>> It's not talking.
>> You're literally just I'm crazy cuz I thought this YEAH,
I WAS NOT IN A right >> I I if you if you had actually
>> keep talking about it. >> Uh-huh. If you had actually
listened to the conversation,
I keep saying that we are in the best place ever.
But a lot of
>> that does not that that actually makes it so much worse.
It's crazy. He did say that, but that makes it to me so much
worse that he's like, I'm going to bring up this that is obviously
like every single person on planet Earth could tell it's inappropriate
to be discussing on a live stream. And he's like, yeah, I I I
would be mad. I said we're in the best place ever. It's like
when I said, "Don't be mad that I say I wish I didn't rescue
you." Like, right? Cuz I wish someone else rescued you because
it made our relationship weird. But I love you. I I want you
to be alive. But like, I just wish I hadn't rescued you. Like,
he just keeps saying this. >> Like,
I'm still nervous about because I don't know. You You never talked
to me about I don't know,
That would be maybe the sickest thing I've ever done in my entire
life. If I if I get Nick on a call again and I just try to coach
him on how Pisco debates to try to get him to debate like Pisco
in the next one of their arguments. Look, Nick, I I understand
your problem is you don't extract concessions. Okay? What you
need to do is work on extracting concessions from the people
you're debating. So when you when you say things to them, you
need to say like, "Is this true? Yes or no? Yes or no? Is this
true?" [laughter]
>> Oh, could you imagine teaching Nick how to debate like
that?
>> that would be crazy >> the PTSD stuff is going
for instance. You don't have to talk about it now. I'm just saying
I'll ask and you'll say it's fine. It's like that's fine. It's
your your business. But like from the vantage point I'm at. It
makes it hard for me to to know, you know, well, will that stuff
happen again? like you know the you taking things out of context
you being in an altered state and if it does what's my first
>> PTSD does not address that it addresses >> I didn't
say it does I didn't say it does I don't you okay your altered
state was because you were in a emotionally charged state which
is what the PTSD deals with and it mixed with a chemical
right like that's just what happened
and and so obviously one half >> like I he says dude Dude,
I I don't think this is happening, but like he's basically trying
to get on record that she's like having
I feel like he's trying to get this on record for some purpose.
Like somebody said that the joke about the Britney Spears thing.
Like yeah, he's
he's so badly trying to get like all this stuff on record right
now that I'm like, dude, why? This shouldn't be on the record.
You shouldn't have this on the record. I'm telling you, you shouldn't
put this on the record with your wife if this is that much of
a problem that you can't bring it up on stream. can't not bring
it up on stream randomly. Get the [__] out, man.
>> This is [__] This really It's just weird.
And I
>> Oh, man. The emotional state. And that's the piece of
the puzzle where you don't really talk about which is fine. That's
You're right. >> But like my point to chat was
sometimes like, you know, >> what do you mean a mix with
a chemical?
>> It's a breakup. You shouldn't be uh streaming it, dude.
It's not This isn't a breakup.
I'll bet you so much money this is not a breakup. >> What
are you [__] talking about? It's all emotional. >> The
vance. >> That's not my PTSD from No, no, no, no, no, [laughter]
no, no. That's not what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying. No,
no, no, no, no, no.
>> State was the PTSD.
I'm saying
the other thing that al also alters your state is the vivance
stuff. Obvious
it's two separate things I'm listing
because you asked why am I talking about the PTSD. I'm saying
it's well it's because it's composed of two different >> No,
it's a god and my
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'M NOT SAYING
IT IS. >> OKAY. What the [__] >> For
the fifth time, for the fifth time, I am not saying your PTSD
is the cause
like or sorry.
the stream.
Oh, do you think she cut it? Oh, he muted. I see he muted.
>> Hold on. And here we go.
Right now. There we go. What? >> Every time that >> Oh,
you're going to trauma bait, right? No, I'm not.
>> You're going to trauma bait right now.
>> that's a new one. >> Do not stop. Every time you
try to come in here and argue me and put it on stream. First
of all, stop. It's making me feel alone and defenseless again.
Can you Can you not understand how you saying this is not helping
my PT?
Do you see how when you do the thing you're doing, I could keep
talking and yapping all day? >> Bro, your PTSD
alone right now cuz you're just trying to come out even with
a bunch of people in your chat. It's not >> I'm not even
looking at what they're saying coming at me, but it emotionally
makes me feel
again. Can you please stop?
>> Please, Nick, stop this. Oh my god.
>> Dude. Dude. Oh, I don't want to read this chat. This
chat's going crazy. >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. First of all,
you can say
I don't want you to do this or I I I would like you not to do
this. But for you to say this IS NOT >> IGNORE THAT. I
HAVE sex
before and you ignore it. >> Well, it's because you see
you're doing this thing where >> don't [__]
listen to me. Ju just for the record, you're talking over me,
so I'll just let you go. But like
you literally three times. Dude, dude.
I forgot this is like this is actually I swear this is worse.
This is like worse than the last time we watched. Like I thought
he was getting better about this or something because he was
doing the Ice Poseidon content. This is actually worse.
This is actually worse than
>> Three times. You told me.
>> Please just stop this. Stop interrogating me.
>> I'm not interrogating you. >> WHY ARE YOU AT THE
streaming here? Stop.
>> Do you see how when you say like I'm interrogating you
that that might be perceived as like I'm doing something bad
here when I'm the person who's like kind of been wronged. Do
you see how like when you say I'm interrogating you how that's
like really [__] with my
>> Please stop this. Stop interrogating me. >> I'm
not interrogating you. >> WHY ARE YOU AT THE stream in
here? Stop. >> I'm I'm not asking you a question. >> I
don't want to be your [__] spectacle content. >> I'm
not asking you a question.
I'm trying to correct something.
You said three times that I keep asserting
that your PTSD is from chemical reasons. I don't I didn't say
that and I don't think that. So, LET'S JUST CLEAR.
>> NO WAY.
THE TUCKER CARLSON. OH, WAIT. Hold on. I see how he's going to
No, I see how he's going to delineate this for a sec. Hold on.
No, no, no, no, no. Hold on.
That had a rule about not filming people who don't want to be
filmed. I don't know, man. You'd think so.
This is pretty crazy.
He's saying your PTSD is caused by a chemical thing. No, you're
saying I said that, but I didn't say that. I was saying it was
like PTSD mixed with a chemical thing. So, he's going to differentiate
there. Okay. very very specific,
very pedantic. He's got to correct his wife. He can't stop doing
this now cuz she said something incorrect. That point right there,
that has to be addressed >> the air there. I don't think
that I didn't say that. What I'm saying is that your altered
state,
meaning you acting different, the thing you yourself referenced,
you said that you were in an altered state, that you weren't
yourself, right? I'm saying that that is a combination of two
factors. One being the PTSD, one being the chemical. I'm not
weighing in on how much of each is
That's the the statement. I'm using the words that you used and
you're redefining them as we speak.
You said the word altered,
>> I didn't. You started with that and I'm using your term.
Is that understandable to you? Are we on the same page now that
I'm not saying your PTSD is that you're confusing the two because
you're using words? This is why I knew earlier when you were
in my chat, you were saying things that were um a little bit
too uh composed
>> as she like curls up into the fetal position, rolling
around, crying her eyes out in a ball. He's like, "I'm getting
the sense you're a little emotional right now." [laughter] I
swear to God, he's about to drop that. I'm getting the idea.
I'm I'm starting to see some emotion seep into your logic here,
Amaranth. >> Using the two because you're using words.
This is why I knew earlier when you were in my chat, you were
saying things that were um a little bit too uh
You said altered state. Fine.
But now when I say altered state, you think I'm talking about
your PTSD?
Are you saying the PTSD caused you to lie
about me?
Cuz if that's the case, then I feel very offended that you didn't
get it resolved earlier.
[laughter]
Dude, this is so sick.
He's so
I need you to I need you to understand something, okay?
I feel like you can hear the audio of her like curling up further
and further into a ball as as you hear him talk more. She's like
more trying to curl up into a bar uh ball. She's like got her
ears covered. Okay.
She's like trying anything to be small and like non-combat and
he just keeps like walking over and he's like, >> "Do you
see how when you do this right
I don't feel good in this relationship
>> When we watch
pigeon or armor
Jesus Christ, Raven Ruben, thank you. Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Holy [__]
>> I'm going backwards. I had to I I'm playing the replay
the last 15 seconds. I got to watch this whole thing. >> Listen,
I feel very offended that you didn't get it resolved earlier.
>> I didn't go forward, did I?
>> No, I didn't.
I need you to I need you to understand something, okay?
I don't feel good in this relationship
>> Today when we were watching or
no way.
She's chipping out.
She's literally [laughter] chipping out.
Oh my god. I can't breathe.
Oh my god.
Oh my god. What the
What the [__]
Today when we were watching or yesterday
For the record, I'm just standing like 20 ft away.
>> Possible soundboard. Yeah. >> You know what? We're
going to just put some distance
>> cuz I don't even want the
Wouldn't
want anybody to say that I'm like not treating you right. Wouldn't
want anybody to say that like I'm kind of being an here. Wouldn't
want anybody to think anything like that.
I just don't think it's fair
to be able to say, "Oh, yeah. I mean, I I lied about this. I
lied about that, but like it's altered state. You can understand,
right?" It's like, "Okay, but can we talk about that?" It's not
true.
Or do you think it's true, right? Like saying altered state.
>> Okay. Anybody who has ever once virtue signaled about
Max, if you're not like,
if you're not a thousand times more upset about this guy, you're
crazy.
If you've made a point about Mr. Girl abusing his girlfriend
or something and you can watch this content and not feel like
this is a problem, okay, this is like a thousand times worse
than anything that was done to Shaylen. It's like so it's actually
so much worse. It's crazy.
doesn't say it's true or untrue. It just
like it's a non secular, right?
If you're saying like, "Oh, this is untrue.
It's categorically untrue.
I only felt [clears throat] that way because it's an altered
state." Sure.
But to say
I'm in an altered state, so it's untrue. I'm in an altered state.
It just feels like you're kind of like using it as a uh
plea the fifth.
Dude, some
some people use background music. Some people just literally
have this as ambiance in the background. Her just sobbing repeatedly.
I'm in an altered state. So, it's untrue. I'm in an altered state.
It just feels like kind of like using it as a uh
plea the fifth.
It it should never
ever come to that. And if it does come to that, like obviously
I think uh a a correction and an apology is warranted cuz it
sounds like to me that she still thinks that.
>> I think it sounds like she does owe you an apology,
Nick. You should go in there and extract your concession. Okay?
You should go in there and not just refuse to leave until she
apologizes. I really think it sounds like to me from everything
I've heard so far, she really owes you an apology actually,
you know.
Oh, yeah. I'm definitely a a big piece of massive turd.
I feel like I've learned from this >> She's literally She's
literally >> Like it's just I get it. like see like there's
like stuff to form for content and then there's also just like
I just want answers clearly and you know
without reservation
like even though now it'd be more content to for me to get worked
up
as a relational thing
I'm not
honestly If he was just screaming at her, I feel like this would
be better.
Like, at least he could be like emotional. He's sitting here
totally calm while she sobs and sobs and sobs.
Like, at least if he was emotional,
that could be better. Maybe like then I would understand. But
now when he's like, I'm just going to get I'm going to be really
calm right now. >> I'm going to get worked up. It's like
not going to be possible
because I know that if I get worked up,
it's easier to paint me as the villain.
I mean I I'm of the opinion that like I've conducted a lot of
this relationship wrong and I probably should have been way more
resolute about
a lot of certain boundaries
because
but I understand that like
you know it isn't like
if you've been doing something another way you can suddenly be
like, you know what, I want to do things a different way. That's
jarring for your partner.
And so, you kind of just have to live with the bed that you've
made and, you know, hopefully
steer it over time
to where you want it to be.
But like, this is the ridiculous part to me, which is like I
feel like what I'm asking for is simple, but she's trying to
be stubborn about it.
All I want is for her to say, "Hey,
you know, altered state or not, you can say that if you want."
I mean, like, that's that's irrelevant. I'm just after the fact
that like, and we're agreeing that this is categorically untrue,
and there's never been anything to even indicate or hint or imply
that this is even
a Why do you need that on the record on a stream, though? Like
that that is I like I understand why that seems really suspicious.
I to somebody who's like got like paranoid like who's got paranoid
delusions. You're literally getting her to put on the record
that there is no problem with you. That's a weird thing to press
for, dude.
[clears throat] Because I feel like it's like, okay, you're an
altered state, but yes, it's obviously not true. Done.
um when I was in a bad state of mind saying you wished you hadn't
saved me. Sounds like I messed up an inside job. Blah blah blah
blah blah. So she's saying I don't think that now and I was just
tripping on trauma and hurt feelings. That is saying it's I was
in a bad state of mind. I know it's not true. Now I'll be real.
I think she probably still has like concerns about this and you're
almost certainly exacerbating them by doing this. Right. you're
arguing arguing logic when I said already said I understand and
it was a bad state of mind like she probably still has concerns
about this. She doesn't want to put on record that like oh this
didn't happen. So if you need that I again you probably just
need
a walk or something
like
you understand how somebody says they're paranoid that you're
doing this thing to them and you say I want you to go on video
right now while I'm streaming while I'm live streaming and say
I've never done this thing to you.
Like why do you need that? Why?
What? That one that looks crazy. Two I understand exactly like
you have to understand exactly that fuels every delusion they're
talking about. Are you out of your mind? >> The alternative
is to say altered state.
It's like, okay, so it's not true. Altered state,
BUT LIKE >> I ALREADY SAID THAT. I SAID THAT.
Can you not >> Can you not yell at me? You're the one [__]
just here in my room. >> I'm asking you if you can [screaming]
stop your >> I GAVE YOU WHAT YOU WANTED. YOU'RE ACTUALLY
ALL YOU WANT. I ALREADY SAID IT IN THE CHAT. I SAID IT IN PERSON.
>> You're you're you're literally
>> I already said it in the chat and I said it in person.
I gave you what you wanted. What more do you want now?
I understand. She said it really loud and really
Okay. Not actually. That's a joke. Just I'm trying to not put
the incelss off so they can understand this. Okay, I understand
how she said it and that was like my affect how you hear it,
but she just said all the things.
>> I ALREADY SAID THAT. I SAID THAT SO MANY
>> Can you not yell at me? >> You don't want to.
[laughter] >> I'm asking you if you CAN STOP YELLING. >> GIVE
ME WHAT YOU WANT. YOU'RE ACTUALLY WHAT YOU WANT. I ALREADY SAID
IT IN THE CHAT. I SAID IT IN PERSON. >> You're you're you're
literally interrupting me. >> Stop. ALL YOU WANT TO DO
IS [__] MILK YOUR [__] CONTENT THESE
DAYS. Just >> You're You're literally >> Don't milk
your content somewhere else. >> You're literally You're
literally interrupting me midpoint. >> NO WAY TO DO IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
You're I believe you have my stapler. I believe I believe you
have my stapler.
>> I believe you have my stapler. >> You're literally
interrupting me midpoint. I need TO DO IT SOMEWHERE
I'm not going to be disrespectful like
[laughter] I got to play the clip again. I got to PLAY THE CLIP
AGAIN. >> NOT MAKING SENSE. YOU >> DUMBASS. [screaming]
>> If you want to talk, >> you're the one [__]
streaming my [__] PTC. Can you stop?
Can you please stop?
I'll be honest.
I feel like as a third party to this, I feel way worse about
streaming this than Nick does. I'm almost positive I feel worse
about this than he does.
>> Streaming your PTSD.
What? >> I told you when you come in here WITH YOUR CHAT,
IT MAKES ME FEEL like you can press it again. >> That was
the accepted. [laughter]
>> No, that was the first time I've ever heard that. Let's
be honest. >> YOU'RE STILL DOING IT THOUGH. YOU DON'T CARE.
THEN >> I I'VE I'VE MOVED. >> STOP. YOU'RE THE ONE
being >> See, you're you're such a you're such a pernitious
like person with those implications. You made it sound like you've
said this in the past. No, >> I'm telling you, SO PLEASE
STOP. YOU COULD SAY I'M SORRY AND GO, BUT YOU
>> I No, I I I moved >> for an APOLOGY THAT'S NOT
EVEN WARRANTED CUZ I ALREADY TOLD YOU I DON'T FEEL that way.
I moved far away and I'm talking to my chat. And
>> you're talking to them within earshot of her, which
seems like given her state, given she literally chimped the out
five minutes ago.
She literally chimped the out. Okay. It seems like you could
have moved more than like 5t outside the door. Maybe >> still
in this room. You were still streaming me.
Stop. Yeah, because I'm actually hoping that LIKE >> WAIT,
HOPING I ALREADY TOLD YOU TO BEGIN WITH. I don't think that.
>> Can Can you not see that you you interrupted me midway
through a sentence and that's not the only thing I'm talking
about?
>> My god,
why do you have to do this on stream? IF YOU WANT TO ACTUALLY
TALK TO ME, YOU CAN DO IT OFF STREAM.
>> SO, when you went to my chat and typed the message,
was that >> I TRIED TO CALL YOU BEFORE?
CAN I >> I WANT A HUSBAND INSTEAD OF A CLAP CHASING STREAMER.
>> Keep it up and you'll get neither.
What the
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> I want a husband INSTEAD
OF A [__] CLAP CHASING STREAMER.
Keep it up and you'll get neither.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
[__] claping streamer.
>> Keep it up and you'll get neither. >> Sorry. This
guy is out of his mind in like the funniest and most destructive
ways known to man. Like, I'll be
dude, I'll be clear.
This is horrible. This is actually horrible. I'm finding it funny
because it's like terri like it's terrible. It's not funny because
it's like just funny in a vacuum. It's like funny because of
how offputting. Okay. It's crazy how this is. He acts like he's
the girl with the o eirl with the o. He really does.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe you did say it in the chat, but I did not see that message.
And I don't think it's that crazy to
>> You did. You read it. You kept YOU KEPT FINDING WAYS
TO ARGUE WITH IT. I KEPT SAYING IT IN THE MESSAGE AND YOU JUST
IGNORE IT. ALL YOU DID WAS FOCUS ON THE PROBLEM. The only one
I saw was the one that I read.
And that one >> Yeah. And I told you I don't think that
way anymore. >> Well, hey, look. You keep saying, "No,
no, stop, stop, stop. You You keep saying
no." The other one was just
Well, if that's what you're saying, it doesn't make any sense
to me. That's why I
>> That one was a one-s sentence liner, right? And it ended
with you saying,
"I was in an altra state." And the first half of it
didn't say it wasn't true. >> Honestly, I don't think that
I was in a
>> Just to just to be clear, when somebody says, "I wasn't
in my right mind when I said that," that means it's not true.
That is an admission that it's not true. Obviously, obviously,
that is an admission that it's not true. The implication is because
of the altered state of mind, I said something that is
Now, you could just ask, you could easily just ask, "So, you're
so you're saying it's wrong then?" Jesus Christ,
>> Okay, I'm [clears throat] trying to explain something
to you, okay?
That you don't think that
and you're in an altered state of mind. It still doesn't say,
which listen to me here.
I never said anything that should give a reasonable person or
even, you know, a pretty nervous person any reason to believe
that I would plot. It doesn't make any sense. >> Obviously,
it doesn't. We're thinking logically my abos should at this time.
>> Oh, I'm not talking about logical. I'm saying look.
>> Um, now realize that there are some women out there
after watching these clips would pro probably still date Nick
because he's attractive. Well, only if they watch part of the
clips. Nick is also, and I don't say this to like take shots
at him, he's also very insecure. And that comes through a lot
in the clips. And I do not believe he's attractive enough given
the given this and the insecurity to pull that off. The clout
might be different though. The clout might be enough. He does.
He is clouded up now. He's hanging out with with Ice Boseidon.
He's doing a lot of crazy. The clout could be enough. But I think
this whole thing going on with the insecurity. That's that's
tough one. >> I'm saying I didn't do anything at all
that would influence someone to think that whether they're logical
or whether they're being, you know, emotional. Maybe if we say
that you're being, you know, not yourself and hyper paranoid,
you know, in a, you know, kind of uh uncontrolled state. Sure.
But I never said anything threatening to you ever. >> No,
I never said you said anything >> Okay. But just for the
record, when you say I could see you plotting to have me killed,
that implies that there is that, >> He's back to arguing
it. He's back to arguing it. when you try to have me thrown in
jail for clothes mining you and saying you want me to rot and
laugh in my face.
>> Oh, okay. First of all, first of all, first of all,
that's me calling the cops, which you've already done on me like
nine times at that point. Um,
I still So, see, see, this is what I'm talking about. When you
say that, you're justifying you're saying >> I'm not justifying
it. You're saying I don't know how I said anything. I'm wait
like you did >> so that that's you you were literally okay
I I look look if you want to resolve this it's it's it's time
for you to listen for a second
if I say I never did anything that would make a reasonable person
or even an unreasonable person feel this way and you go well
you did you know call the
in an altered state too >> feel what way I didn't finish
my >> I was in danger at the time. But obviously I don't
think that now. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait. You see, you're
maybe you're not meaning to do this, but like when you say you
feel like you're in danger,
>> I I know. I know. I know. I know. I'm trying to I I
know that's not the point I'm making. Can I actually make the
>> dude? Where I'm trying to find the clothesline clip.
[clears throat] Can somebody tell me when we covered this stuff
originally? I'm looking for a date so I can find this clip in
my downloads folder. Give me a second.
Where is this
Where is this [__]
I don't know where the I put this [__]
I'm looking for it. I'm looking for it. I got to find it right
now. Actually important that we find this. Okay,
we're looking. It's like July sometime, right? I think May, maybe.
No, there's no way we go back to May. It's got to be July. It's
got to be July.
Looking in June. May 21st. Okay, May 21st. Thank you.
What is this?
Oh, I don't see anything here.
Maybe it's this?
I can't I literally can't find it. I'll find it. Hold on. I'll
find it later. >> When you say you feel like you're endangered,
but I don't want to clarify, but not from me. >> Be on
your Twitter. It would used to be on my streamable, but I don't
pay for streamable, so it got deleted.
>> No, at the time it DID FEEL LIKE THAT. YES, CORRECT.
I I'm saying that I feel like that now. There was >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god, this is so crazy. So you No, no. So, let me explain.
So, you called the cops on me at that point? Like probably actually
nine times. Like I don't that I like you >> over the course
of our life. >> No, no, no. Like like over the course of
the fights? >> No, I did not. >> No, no, hold on.
It was not even me. It >> Sure. Okay, fine. Okay, fine.
Fine. Like uh Angelica and people called. Sure. Okay. But like
you called the cops a
>> I don't remember calling it during the fights. No, I
know you called it. I know the chat called it. Even like the
day
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I'm not even saying if >> Okay,
finally. I found it. Okay, so we could we could just find the
clip of
Yes. Oh, it's a God damn it. >> They said Okay, we're coming
now. >> Upload it to I'm saying >> Are you actually
This is on stream, dude. Are you actually saying you never called
the cops while we're on stream? Are you serious? >> No,
I didn't. I >> I got it. I don't want the reactions.
>> Yeah, I called them. So then that's on that's that's
on stream then. >> Remember it wasn't me nine times. >> Okay.
Okay. So let's drop the nine times. So we agree that you called
multiple times while on stream.
>> I remember >> it's on stream, dude. >> I
remember once.
>> I'm never not going to see the hutch moments now. I'm
going to see every single hutch moment every single time.
Here's
the here's their fight. Nick, remember Nick said that she tried
to clothesline him, like hurt him, right? This is this is how
he
>> he basically was ready to he was calling the cops on
her over this clip.
>> Just didn't realize it got recorded.
>> No, you cannot.
DO NOT DISMISS ME. >> I DID NOT.
>> Pulling my arm out. God, what a little
>> I'm going to put my arms out,
He instantly snaps to the camera. It's so funny. I used to have
this where I could just swap between the frames, but like the
frame change here, but he gets grabbed. Watch. Like, it's literally
right there. You see his like head like snap to the camera and
then he points at it. It's so funny. It's like this blurred.
You see his his head just snaps to the camera.
incredible stuff.
the day they pointed the loaded Glocks in my face.
What are you talking about?
>> The the the day when >> you mean the day where
she got pistolh whipped by the people with the load of Glocks
and had them pointed to her head while she was like going through
her phone. The day that you're you're actually reference There's
no way that he's referencing that day. >> Just tip five
that way.
>> She was such a penicious person.
How can you not see that? I guess I was the deluded one this
whole time. I am going to keep you.
>> Okay. [laughter]
Thank you very much for the donation, Nick Lee. Nick Wick Lee
with the
>> You remember the day when
people called in and said,
>> which is why that I beat you unconscious with your microphone
and the police came and they put Glocks in my face. You realize
the cops.
Wait, [clears throat]
we saw a part of that >> that day prior [snorts] to the
chat swatting.
You had already called twice on stream. >> No, I don't
remember that.
>> I used to have timelines of all try to find this >> that
you're wrong.
>> And so, >> do you think he's going to go find
those clips or is he just going to go chat find the clips? and
you dial and you start talking to the operator. Are you not counting
that or is that count? >> Is wait is one of those times
I feel like one of those times is literally where he's like threatening
to leak the door code and right
I feel like one of those times where is where he's literally
going like hang up with the cops now or I'll like leak the door
code. I can't remember why she called the cops there. He did
leak the door code. Yes.
account because like you know calling the police like you can
be playing a podantic game here but it's like >> no way
no okay
I'm going to say a toss thing about Nick because I told him a
hundred times it's pedantic not podantic and he just dropped
a podantic
dude he he did this just knowing that I was going to review this
VOD and he's Just in case you thought anything changed from the
10 hours of conversation you had with me. Podantic. Pedantic.
Podantic. Pedantic. Podantic.
Nick once and then they called me back. Them calling me back
doesn't count as me calling them.
I called once because you were leaking the gate code.
>> Yeah, but you realize that that that's like you're wasting
resources by calling 911 for that. >> Sabotage borderline.
Ah, I have this really loud.
>> No, he has it really loud.
>> Either way, um, >> dude, a bunch of people are
just going to keep Yeah, Maximus noticed how loud it was and
he decided to sub. Um, I think I'm guessing a lot of people are
going to start subbing to just annoy him while he's having this
argument. >> Before I called the cops on you one time,
you had called the cops on me >> multiple times. >> Fine.
Sub. So, can I can I can I can I finish the statement before
you disagree with it?
Even if we only alleged that that day was one time,
there were other days where it happened. >> Are you saying
on stream I called multiple times? >> Um, a mix, right?
Like I know some of them were off, but regardless, the point
is when I called the cops on you, I was also offream,
right? Later on, later on I got on stream, but when you closed
by me, I was off stream because if I was on stream, they would
have seen it, right? So, obviously, I was all >> There's
no way. There's no [__] way on this planet of Earth.
He is trying to gaslight on this one, too. There is no way that
there we literally have the video. Nick, the video is out there.
Nick, are you serious?
Dude, I'm I actually don't know what to say. I actually am speechless.
There is no
chance.
What's up, Miss Andy Black? Hello. Uh there's no chance that
he's doing this. That's crazy, dude. >> I was also off
stream, right? Later on, later on I got on stream, but when you
closed me, I was off stream because if I was on stream, they
would have seen it, right? So, obviously, I was also off stream.
So, like I don't think you can really say that. >> Okay,
sure.
>> The clos line, by the way. The clothes line. Let's Let's
watch the clos line one more time. One more time. Just for a
No, you cannot.
DO NOT DISMISS ME. I DID NOT [screaming]
>> pulling my arm out. God, what a little
>> dude. The commentary from her as she walks back into
the house is just crazy. What a little snowflake. >> So,
so, so, so then either way, it's multiple of your calls versus
one of my call. I don't think you have a right to say, "Well,
that made me feel like you might plot to kill me." Cuz it's like
if that's all it takes. >> You saying you want me to rot
any of my rot in prison? Then that Yeah. That mixed with the
whole I wish I didn't save you and then saying divorce. >> Can
you not understand? First of all, first of all, okay. So, so
see see that's justifying right there. You're saying that because
I called the cops and because I made comments about I wish the
cops would arrest you that day
that that makes you think I would plot to you.
>> No, no, no, no, no. See, see, you're justifying it's
either reasonable or
>> Yeah, that makes me that made me feel that way. Obviously,
I don't think that >> No, I'm saying I I I'm I'm not asking
you how you felt cuz we talked about your altered state. I'm
saying do you think that is a reasonable conclusion?
>> No, I'm not. >> Okay. Okay. No, no. I I I I Can
you You're overexplaining here. I'm just trying to clarify.
You're overexlaining. I don't need the explanation.
You know, if you say it's unreasonable, I get it. Then then we're
on the same page. We don't got to keep beating a dead horse.
I'm just going to tell you something. It's like when you say
I did this because of that, you have to understand that when
you say it that way, everyone listening is going to be like,
you have a logical
I don't know. I Dude, this guy's gonna
Someone made a joke about Bretler taking
Destiny should take notes. Whatever this is, it's actually making
me go like, "Dude, I don't know if this is worth it. I don't
know if I could I don't know if I could cover this. I don't know
if I can cover this. This guy is like actually just the wor You
listen to this guy argue and it's like the worst experience of
my entire life. This is crazy. Wall-to-wall insanity the whole
>> You way more than doxing me. Whatever this is, this
is like uh this is actually how to get me to stop watching whatever
the you're doing on stream. >> Keep beating a dead horse.
You're beating a dead horse. When she when she chimped out, that
was just beating a dead horse. Okay, I get it. You're traumatized.
You're upset. I get it. Whatever.
Whatever, [__]
I'm just going to tell you something. It's like when you say
I did this because of that, you have to understand that when
you say it that way, everyone listening is going to be like
you have a logical
inference between these two things. But what you're actually
saying is that it is illogical, but this made me feel I can when
I say when I'm talking about it, I mean, I can see how somebody
who's been through a traumatic event and hurt by something that
their partner said combined with those feelings could think that.
But I'm not saying that it is logical think that I'm saying I
could see how I would get to that point. Yes, >> I know.
I'm just wishing that you could understand that well enough to
not chain those two together when we're just kind of touching
on it, right? Cuz you just said, "Well, of course I feel that
way because it's like, well, hold on. Of course you feel that
way." Then you're you're actually very strongly saying it's a
logical thought even though I know you don't mean that. You see
what I'm saying? Like you use language in >> No, she's
not. She's not. She's not. She is saying, "Okay, here's the thing.
Nick thinks when you have a when you're like delusional or or
paranoid or
or what what was the other word?" Basically, when you're having
um psychosis or you're delusional, you're paranoid, most of your
brain is still working fine. You're still like able to walk around.
You're still able to see everything just fine. They're like little
things that break. It's not everything. So, she had a fact like
about you that was broken, right? And she took the obvious logical
step based on that broken fact.
She thought you were trying to get her killed. She thought that
based on some things like basically minorly changing events that
actually happened that she had trauma around. So, she's probably
explicitly not remembering them correctly,
right? And she you you just twist those ever so slightly and
she starts to get this idea that you're planning to kill her,
which is wrong. And she knows it's wrong now. And she's saying
based on that idea, I did the rest of the stuff. And it's like,
yeah, that is how people with delusions work. That's literally
how it works, man. I don't know if he needs somebody to explain.
He just needs somebody to explain it to him. But like the the
logical progression of I thought you were trying to kill me for
a totally illogical reason. So I logically followed up by calling
the lawyer and saying here's like the evidence of this at a later
time even after you'd come out of the delusion and then you went
back into a similar delusion. Right? That's why these things
are pernicious and don't go away right away is because they are
based on like some feeling they have that is likely to be like
like it's based on some evidence. If you don't understand that
it's based on some evidence they're seeing and if you can't be
empathetic to that then
that's just a really difficult situation. You got to get that
fixed,
right? He thinks it's like losing your temper. He thinks that
basically
like she maybe was a little angry because of Viveance and so
she like concocted this thing and then used it again later when
it was convenient. And it's like no, I'm I'm guessing she really
did feel that way sincerely. And probably even when she said
she didn't feel that way anymore, there were probably still things
lingering there where she was suspicious still, right?
I'm guessing. But it like sort of lowers down. It's like not
as in her face. And then something bad happens and it pops back
up. It like crops back up again. And it's the same thing. It's
the same
But it seems like he's just totally unaware that this could happen
>> in a way that benefits you greatly. >> I'm not
trying to do that. I'm just saying I can see how I would get
to that point with my with my state of mind. I can understand
how I might think that, but it is not a logical thing to think.
You have to understand that the way you're communicating is like,
look, maybe you're being genuine here, but it sounds very disingenuous.
>> You are like you you just you just told me that like,
well, of course, I understand my illogic. It's like, dude, that's
not what I'm saying, asking, and no one's asking that.
>> Yeah. He's just not
he's just not hearing it, right?
It's like there's a variable. The variable is X. Reality is something
you are like inserting and and the equation makes no sense. But
she's saying, well, I didn't think that X was equal to this thing
or sorry, I thought X was equal to this thing, which was a delusion
and wrong. But based on that, then the equation is like correct.
Call the cops. Call the [__] lawyer. Try to get like
a restraining order. I think this guy's a vampire trying to kill
me.
Yeah, that makes perfect, man. Of course, even when us ourselves
have an illogical. >> Well, I think she has seen a doctor.
I think this was based on I think this was based on a couple
of things. So, they thought it was her overdosing on her um Adderall
prescription the one time or Viveance or something. And then
like the other times have been stress and PTSD related that she's
in like a really stressful state and she'll kind of have some
delusions, but they're not like insane. The vampire thing is
new. I've never heard this one before. The stuff before was like
it was it was like delusional a little bit, but there was like
religious stuff going on and it wasn't like it wasn't totally
disconnected from reality. It was like it wasn't that bad. The
vampire thing sounds a bit like a psychotic break of some kind.
Um that seems kind of
But I again I don't even know how these connections break or
like what is going on there is why you probably need a a professional
to help you through it. thought. Of course, we understand it.
It's our thought. It's it's I'm saying that no one else can understand
that. And when you tell people that publicly, like my husband
is plotting, had me killed, they're thinking, "Holy shit." Cuz
they're inferencing that you have uncovered some reasons. But
in reality, you're saying there's no reasons. I'm just not feeling
myself. You see that? Most people are just later.
Um, the raptured thing, to be honest with you, winter guy, the
raptured thing sounded to me like um that sounded to me like
he was playing it up a lot.
Like the way he described it just sounded to me like he was playing
it up extremely that like probably he experienced her having
some kind of um episode before and he was making that an episode
when it wasn't. It was just like some understandable like religious
She had like a bit of a religious awakening after the really
traumatic stuff with the break-in. And I think most of what she
was saying made perfect sense. She was basically like she said,
"Oh, I feel like this character because of like this." And he's
like, "You said you were this character. You said you were this
religious character." And she's like, "No, I said I felt like
that. What are you talking about?" >> And so I think he
sort of made that into some kind of episode. The vampire thing,
I don't know, though. That sounds more serious. I was way out
of line.
It was not that he never >> Oh, [__] I should
back up here and just let him talk again because I'm talking
over him. I Sorry. That's my impression. After they talked through
something, right after they talked through it, that was my impression.
I still don't know the actual reality of it. It could be that
it was a like, you know, a major episode of some kind. And but
I I got the impression it was exact. >> My husband had
this plotting me. They're thinking, "Holy shit." because they're
inferencing that you've have uncovered some reasons, but in reality,
you're saying there's no reasons. I'm just not feeling myself.
You see that? Most people would just later say
I was way out of line. It was not that he never gave me indications
of that. You know, um that's just something, you know, that should
not have ever been said. Like that's how they would say it. They
wouldn't say, "Well, you have to understand that I
that that's justifying it.
you you just have to stay away from it. Like like for instance
the whole hand job thing. Should I be like well you know how
I could see it like you don't want me to say that. You want me
to just say you know I trust you right and that you know you
were obviously more in the know than I was and that's it. You
don't want me to sit there and explain why it was reasonable.
And so I feel the exact same way, which is that when you sit
there and you go to chat and you go, "Well, you know, he did
do these things." It's like, dude, you were justifying it because,
>> dude, I keep seeing I keep seeing um Nicks from this
chat in his chat trying to explain to him like, "Hey, here's
how you could act like a human being right now." But she said
she was dealing with trauma from the robbery, which makes these
thoughts not logical. Good luck. That's definitely going to work.
in
in a court >> talk about how crazy I am then if you don't
[__] want me to say why I was >> The point
wasn't to talk about you being crazy. It was to dichomize the
fact that we came from a very very very very rocky
>> Dichomize the fact that we came from a rocky place.
It was to dichomize the fact that we came from a rocky place.
Okay, Nick
guy. This guy does not know what words mean. No wonder he says
podant. very very good place and then that like my big concern
is that because we don't really talk about your thing and I don't
know if I can or should broach the subject.
What's the thing? We don't talk about her thing. What thing?
The thing where she has like delusional episodes
because we don't talk that's you're talking about her being crazy
on stream.
How is that confusing? I don't know
what is the chance of uh you know wrong word probably but recidivism
like you feeling that altered state way again.
I wasn't I wasn't talking about you be crazy. I was just talking
about how we were in a really good like spot in our relationship
but I was like feeling you know terror at the idea that you might
go crazy again. But I wasn't talking about you being crazy. That's
crazy. Are you crazy? >> Which I I literally brought up
other things like when we were at the movie, you looked over
at me and you basically started talking about the demon thing.
We're watching Zootopia, man. >> I was making a joke cuz
reptilians in the Zootopia
>> was literally [__] all about it.
>> You realize, >> do you see that? Like when Here's
the thing that makes me think Nick is like really gaslighting
here. Um, it's not that I don't believe that she could have these
delusions in other places. It's not like I think he's like particularly
a liar outside of these kinds of where he feels like he's been
wronged. It's that one, he's feels wrong to the situation, so
he does make things up um a lot. And two, when she did have a
delusional thought and she she understands that it was delusional,
right, the vampire thing. She says, "No, I was wrong." And now
she goes, "No, I was joking. Like I was joking about the the
reptilians." It's like, "Oh, yeah." And Nick had talked about
how she started she started watching like more conspiracy stuff
cuz her dad watches conspiracy stuff. Dude, if you were wondering
who to watch this coverage with, okay, I'm like an encyclopedia
on these people cuz I've watched like 40 hours of them fighting.
Okay, so um yeah, she was watching more conspiracy stuff. She's
like, "Oh, reptilians, demons." She's running the Alex Jones
like gauntlet and just makes a joke. That makes total sense to
me. Like that that makes total logical sense that you can make
those jokes and it's funny. And I also even I could even get
towards understanding how he is like, "Well, it's weird that
you made that joke." Like I I was concerned about it. I could
get how he's concerned. What I don't get when you're concerned
about something like that is you going on stream talking about
it. Very >> like when you were doing your episode, you
also made jokes that made me feel like you weren't actually feeling
that way and then you doubled down, right?
>> Okay. It was just a joke because they have to go to
Antarctica to find the reptilians that are buried under the
All right. Well, now
>> you realize that like that is a reference that like
I don't even >> Sure. I understand you haven't.
>> Yeah, but you uh I mean I don't totally understand it,
but like I you understand. I can see exactly based on stories
you've told. By the way, Nick, exactly where she's going with
that. How that makes total sense to me. I just had to go back
to his face.
>> Dude, dude, this is actually
this is wild.
30 minutes before this, she is like dry heaving levels of sobbing
into her pillow trying to get him to stop arguing,
right?
And now, now we're at this point. I need that time stamp really
quick. Now we're at this point and he's like mocking her
>> You realize that like that is a reference that like
I don't even >> Sure, I understand you have it. you're
not on the same [__] conspiracy videos that I've
watched and laughed at. >> And so when you say that to
me like it's like an inside joke, I'm just like, uh, >> sure,
you're right.
You're not on that same
like understanding. I got it,
>> dude. It's the It's literally the Hutch thing. He's
literally like, how could you be in a relationship? How could
you be friends with or literally spouse
uh like a spousal partner with someone who's doing this into
a camera while you say while you're trying to deescalate and
make the situation work and he's like actually doing the touch
faces into the camera to make her look more insane to like crazy
make her to his chat.
baffling. Dude, >> just for the record, you feel like that
is true?
>> No. That's why she said it was a
>> The popular conspiracy.
>> Yeah. I mean, just for the record, I I literally don't
look into any of that
a even if it's true, what the [__] am I supposed
to do?
Nick, sorry. You're uneducated about reptilians and we aren't.
[laughter]
>> Can you stop screaming me now? >> Sure. My my
my my last thing I'm going to say is just that like if you want
my attention like let's be honest here. You can just say like,
"Hey, I'm I I called you." Cuz you can bet your ass my chat will
let me know that. But if you send a long message, they'll also
let me know that. And that's just going to be everyone in chat
seeing it before I even see it. And so like,
I got it. >> Maximus throws another gift in. I get the
music to play.
>> Hard to hate on the timing. That was pretty crazy. All
right. Um, been out of the loop. What is the ETA on their divorce?
Why are they still together? They're never getting divorced.
They're never getting divorced. They're never getting divorced.
They're never getting divorced. Today was like worse in some
ways, but if it ends here, which there's still another hour and
a half of the stream. If it just ends here and they don't go
through this more over the next like day or two, this could maybe
just drop and it won't be as bad as some of the previous situations.
Dude, I have to I I should have taken the time stamp down for
the chimp out. I'm sorry. I literally was in tears listening
to that.
That was unfortunate.
>> Pulls his collar. E. >> Wish I could say we didn't
have a fight for longer, but it has been a very long period.
Um, I honestly don't know where that came from. I feel like me
talking about stuff that happened on a stream that 7,000 people
saw,
I don't know if you can call that talking [__] I
feel like everyone's seen it and me not being allowed to talk
about it is just for no reason painting, you know, me in a certain
light. Cuz if I'm like, I don't want to talk about that, it's
like
this guy land amaranth. Um, he was super ripped, dude. This guy
was at like 8% body fat when they met. Have you seen some of
his cosplay pictures?
I didn't say guy. You didn't. You didn't. This guy was like This
guy was crazy in shape.
He's not that tall, but also Amaranth didn't look like Amaran.
Amaranth looked like kind of more um she was prettier actually,
but she was more boyish, too. It's like a tomboy kind of look.
Yeah,
of course you don't. You know, you abuser.
It's like
I mean I feel like that was like the worst rap ever
was like her saying
oh he could
and then
to sign contracts. It's like
>> Oh both of these are worse now than October 2022.
>> We're not even going to get Dobby references anymore.
That's [__] up. >> That one, you know, I still
she's stepped it back and said that it's
>> Okay, hold on. I'm gonna pause here. Is there more content
on the Nick Lee front for today? Because I'll watch more of this
right now. I'll watch like his post game as he goes and talks
about it as he walks away. But
no, he mutes well soon. Okay. Well, I'm saying that if there's
more content either today or so this is yesterday and then he's
got a stream from today that he's streaming actively right now
and then I'm guessing Amaran's been around or something, too.
We'll take a look.
He goes back. No, I'm not saying he goes back. I'm saying is
there more content where he talks more about this today. He's
going to do like a post game. And I do want to see if there's
more content like of him doing on this today. But that's the
one that's crazy to me because like that one I was like, "Okay,
where do we get that one from?" Cuz that's the thing, right?
Like just like in 22, it's the opposite of what I do. Like when
she goes Doby is >> ah there's 22. There's 22.
>> I've literally never asked her. Dude, how did I how
did I get it in my head that he might not be able to bring up
all of his grievances in the same rant about how he's the victim?
How did I ever think that for two seconds that he might leave
out one of his grievances, okay? Like just like in 22,
it's the opposite of what I do. Like when she goes, "Dobe is
a free elf." It's like
I've literally never asked you to wear less clothing. I've only
ever asked you to wear more clothing.
Like what? >> Wild wild stuff every time. >> There's
some things where it's like,
I never said that. I never implied that. But you found a way
to think that. Sure.
>> Christmas in Texas must be cold. God
>> But then there's things where it's like, I said the
opposite and now you're accusing me of saying
the the what? Like like, oh yeah, now I can wear more clothes.
Bro, I've never ever in my life
asked you to wear less clothing in any situation. In many situations,
I've asked you to wear more appropriate clothing. More clothing.
Cover more.
It's like,
you can't mistake that.
Like, you just can't mistake that.
That's just slander.
And and so it's like the same thing with the whole contract thing.
There's just no way. Like I I I I have never pressured you because
think about this for a second. Ready?
If you think that it gets beyond like honestly the probably probably
the thing that fixes their marriage or gets him to leave or whatever
is that I'm guessing most of his chat won't want to hear him
loop on the same three grievances for multiple hours every single
day and he'll start to lose viewership by doing this. He'll actually
take relationship drama, the thing that fuels more viewers than
anything on any stream on the internet. Okay. He'll find a way
to make it like not work by just consistently looping on the
same three sentences over and over and over and over and over
again. Why the f like if I pressured her into doing something
or signing something that she didn't want to sign, especially
if it's like a like a sponsorship or something and then she later
chooses not to do it, then the
we're we're skipping. We're We're going and we're going to try
to find something. Okay.
Eventually he goes back up to the room
Okay, we keep going. We keep going. Now he mutes. And I think
he's muted for the rest of the stream, it sounds like.
I got to
I just want to know if while he's muted he does like a face at
the camera. like if he'll do like a if he'll do his hutch face
at the camera here while he's muted at some point. I'm going
watch 2x. We're just going to speed through and just see if he
makes a hutch face.
He's clearly arguing strenuously.
Dude,
[laughter]
dude, he's so mad.
He walks away from the room and he's like yelling to himself.
oh, when is the Chile trip? Somebody just asked if is he actually
going to Chile? When is the Chile trip?
Does he not know he's muted? Amaranth must be downstairs or something.
We must have missed her walk by or some.
Does he not sleep? Is he abusing drugs? He does sleep. He doesn't
sleep that much because he is on Adderall, I think, quite a bit.
He streams. He does like the the addied up like or Vance, whatever.
He does like the addied up like 24-hour streams a lot.
Oh, he's back at the door.
So, he's just did a lap, dude. He's starting to look like Hold
on,
dude. Get this guy a hammer. Do you guys see it? It's a Desu
Daisu.
You guys know who I'm talking about,
dude. Get this guy a hammer,
dude. Any Old Boy fans in here?
I mean, obviously he's not as old, okay? But the hair and like
the angle somehow it just looks like it's the same.
Yeah, it's got the same aura.
Dude, Old Boy is such an awesome movie. It's [__]
up, but it's an awesome
Uh, is he Korean, too? No, I don't think he's Korean. This is
like maybe one of the most famous actors out of Korea.
And I don't think I don't think Nick's Korean. I think Nick's
Chinese.
Dude, he's literally just screaming at the door.
Dude, [laughter]
Okay. I don't know how long we can make him I don't know how
long we can watch him just screaming at the door. But damn, that
[__] is funny.
That [__] is [__] funny, man.